[Musique]
les chefs sont prêts les citoyens
attendent des réponses place au débat
bonjour ça va bien
[Applaudissements]
en vrai nous on voit grand pour le
Québec
[Applaudissements]
nous on a un projet de satiété
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un moment historique on peut exprimer le
CE
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que le peuple
en direct de la nouvelle Maison de
Radio-Canada à Montréal voici le débat
des chefs 2022 avec patrice Roy
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs bienvenue
à ce dernier débat de la campagne nous
sommes en effet en direct de la nouvelle
Maison de Radio-Canada Montréal avec
nous François Legault chef la coalition
à venir Québec monsieur Legault bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être là Dominique
Anglade chef du Parti libéral du Québec
madame bonsoir Paul Saint-Pierre plat
Mondon au chef du Parti québécois
bonsoir
Gabriel Nadaud Dubois co porte-parole de
Québec solidaire bonsoir Éric dum chef
du Parti conservateur du Québec bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté de
débattre ce soir vous êtes cinq et c'est
une première cette année pourquoi 5
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
du Québec cinq parties ont des chances
de faire élire au moins un député les
positions sur le plateau ainsi que
l'ordre de parole ont été évidemment
tirés au hasard cinq thèmes ce soir
environnement
coût de la vie économie évidemment
sentez préoccupations éternelle
éducation et finalement immigration et
identité ce soir ma seule tâche sera de
vous permettre d'aller au bout de vos
idées dans l'ordre et le respect je vous
demande de ne pas parler les uns sur les
autres je vais vous donner l'occasion de
répliquer quand un chef est attaqué vous
aurez le temps de répliquer parlant de
temps pour votre temps de parole nous
visons une zone paritaire ça se dit bien
mais les gens pourront suivre à
l'occasion votre temps cumulatif sur un
tableau avant de passer au premier thème
petite question question se réchauffer
vous êtes tous brillants intelligent
vous pourriez faire autre chose dans la
vie mais vous aspirez à être première ou
Premier ministre question est simple
pourquoi pourquoi je reprends votre
expression monsieur
pourquoi vous imposer cette raide 45
secondes chacun je me considère chanceux
dans la vie je viens d'un milieu
populaire puis petit gars de Sainte-Anne
de Bellevue est rendu Premier ministre
et moi mon objectif ça serait tous les
jeunes et tous les outils pour aller au
bout de leur potentiel je pense que du
travail à faire en éducation je pense
qu'on peut faire mieux en économie on a
un grand défi de réduire nos GES c'est
un gros défi de gestion en santé c'est
important là pour moi de protéger notre
français d'arrêter le déclin qu'on voit
donc c'est pour toutes ces raisons que
je m'implique en politique merci
monsieur Legault Dominique Anglade la
question simplement c'est pourquoi faire
la politique pourquoi vous êtes ici
pourquoi vous imposer cette vie
merci de la question je je suis né de
parents qui ont décidé de choisir le
Québec comme terre d'accueil à la plus
de 50 ans les haïtiens qui sont venus
ici ils m'ont inculqué des valeurs
d'engagement et c'est valeurs là je les
incule quotidiennement à mes enfants
puis la raison pour laquelle
fondamentalement je fais de la politique
c'est parce que je souhaite que chaque
personne au Québec peu importe ses
origines peu importe où il habite sur
notre territoire qui soit capable de
vivre dignement puis d'aller au bout de
ses rêves c'est ces valeurs là que je
souhaite avoir qui vont m'habiter comme
première ministre du Québec c'est pour
ça fondamentalement que je fais de la
politique Gabriel Nadaud Dubois vous
avez 45 secondes pour répondre à la même
question bonsoir Monsieur roi bonsoir à
mes collègues bonne question de départ
monsieur Roy moi je suis en politique
parce que je m'inquiète pour l'avenir
parce que l'élection qui est la nôtre en
ce moment au Québec c'est celle de la
dernière chance pour la lutte au
changement climatique je suis devenu
papa récemment je rencontre des jeunes
parents presque tous les jours dans la
rue depuis le début de la campagne
électorale puis il y en a beaucoup du
monde inquiet pour l'avenir au Québec la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on est capable
d'y arriver on a de l'énergie propre en
revanche on a toutes les cartes en main
pour devenir un des pays les plus verts
au monde moi ce que j'aimerais qu'on
fasse là le 3 octobre c'est pas juste
qu'on pense à nous qu'on va aller voter
mais c'est qu'on pense à nos enfants et
à nos petits-enfants parce qu'on a du
pain sur la planche mais je pense qu'on
est capable d'y aller merci Gabriel ado
Dubois pas le simply pierre plat Mondon
45 secondes
et moi je pense qu'il faut faire de la
politique pour aider des gens je pense
la politique peut servir à ça c'est être
utile au fond puis il y a plein de
manières d'être utile dans une société
mais je pense que la politique est l'une
d'entre elles c'est particulier faire de
la politique au Québec parce que c'est
une histoire riche belle et improbable
il parle toujours français depuis les
patriotes il y a toujours eu des gens
pour servir notre destinational pour
qu'un jour on soigne une société normale
qui rayonne partout dans le monde on
soigne société qui est démocratique
libre de ses propres choix et ce destin
il est pas encore il n'est pas encore
atteint mais moi c'est une fierté c'est
un privilège de servir des causes
fondamentales comme notre démocratie la
langue française l'environnement la
dignité des aînés je pense que ça peut
être utile en société merci
Eric dum en conclusion 45 secondes mais
très honnête même sur ouais je moi je
n'avais pas planifié de revenir en
politique mais pour moi la démocratie
fondamentale j'ai déjà mis ma vie en jeu
pour aller à l'étranger pour faire la
promotion de valeur et l'idéal
démocratique et j'en étais rendu au
Québec où je voyais quatre parties puis
il y en avait aucun qui me représentait
j'aurais même pas pu voter en fait et je
me suis dit ça a pas de sens il faut
faire quelque chose moi si je suis
revenu en politique c'est parce que je
veux promouvoir les droits civiques les
libertés individuelles et la démocratie
j'ai l'impression qu'elle était mise à
mal et qui avait très peu de différence
entre les quatre parties qui restaient
je croyais que c'était important
d'offrir une alternative au Québec et je
pense qu'à ce moment-là j'étais la bonne
personne au bon endroit au bon moment et
c'est pour ça que je suis ici ce soir je
pense que il y en a besoin d'une
alternative actuellement au Québec merci
Monsieur Duhem c'était la question
sympathique de la soirée
il y en aura d'autres un peu différent
premier thème l'environnement
l'environnement
je trouve que c'est vraiment un enjeu
important
tout est relié l'environnement la santé
l'économie il devrait faire des choses
qu'on consomme moins que les biens dure
longtemps
que ça soit sur le tapis mais là ça
parle que ça veut relever le tapis
mais la fonderie c'est vrai que ça a des
répercussions majeures on est plusieurs
jeunes à vivre de l'écho anxiété
vous transports
de ça je pense il faut prévoir un pont
c'est plus facile parce que l'argent
devrait nous
de tournante où on peut bientôt puis
pouvoir revenir en arrière quelle est
votre plan environnemental dans les cinq
prochaines années pour en 2050
alors c'est exactement la question que
je vous posais vous avez d'abord 35
secondes pour y répondre monsieur
Legault quel est votre mesure qui va
faire la différence pas en 2050 comme a
dit Monsieur carrier de Saguenay
d'abord ce qui est important c'est
d'agir dans les cinq endroits où il y a
des grs le transport on a beaucoup de
projets de transport collectifs
deuxièmement les industries il faut que
les industries passent à l'électricité
donc assez vert aluminium vert hydrogène
verte je pense qu'on a la meilleure
équipe économique pour faire une
économie verte ensuite l'agriculture
faut vendre plus et acheter plus
localement il y a aussi toute la
question du recyclage donc recyclage des
contenants finalement les bâtiments
l'énergie pop c'est important
l'efficacité énergétique merci Monsieur
Lego Dominique Anglet 35 secondes il y a
quelqu'un dans le voxcobar qui a dit
tout est relié à l'environnement puis
c'est vrai la lutte au changement là je
vais en faire ma responsabilité parce
que ça touche la santé l'éducation
l'économie les ressources naturelles
puis ça c'est ça qui est fondamental et
essentiel et dans tout ce qu'on va
proposer évidemment qu'on va parler de
l'agriculture évidemment qu'on va parler
de la lutte au changement climatique
mais ce qu'on veut d'abord et avant tout
c'est ne pas avoir à opposer
environnement économie c'est de faire un
projet qui soit capable de créer de la
richesse et en même temps de faire en
sorte qu'on soit carbon neutre en 2050
c'est ça l'objectif mais c'est pas qu'on
planifie merci
on a déposé un plan complet et rigoureux
vis-à-vis les changements climatiques et
ce plan a été applaudi par les experts
c'est important de mentionner qu'ici il
y a juste deux parties sur cinq qui ont
déposé un plan complet qui prévoit de
baisser les GS et de les mesurer et donc
notre plan il permet d'une transition
vers la nouvelle économie verte et juste
et on parle en termes très positif donc
les pas question de
réaliser ou de parler de dernière chance
mais vraiment de dire tous ensemble on
est capable de relever ce défi là
gagnant-gagnant merci pour tous Gabriel
ado Dubois 35 secondes et après je vous
rappelle on va passer au débat ouvert
après monsieur duem mais Monsieur
Gabriel à bois d'abord
mais moi je pense qu'en 2022 on peut
plus traiter de la question de
l'environnement des changements
climatiques comme d'une question ou un
communaute ça doit être la colonne
vertébrale de notre projet de société au
Québec faire du Québec je le dis souvent
le pays le plus vert au monde on est
capable de le faire puis monsieur carry
avait bien raison de dire faut arrêter
de parler de 2050 faut que ça commence
maintenant parce que ça fait des
décennies au Québec qu'on pète le
problème par en avant puis quand on fait
ça qu'est-ce qu'on fait ben on est en
train de monter toute une facture pour
nos enfants nos petits-enfants moi
j'accepte pas ça je veux qu'on agisse
maintenant qu'il y a Québec solidaire ça
va commencer le 14 merci
Eric dum 35 secondes ou parce
conservateur du Québec on a une approche
très différente des quatre autres
parties nous on croit qu'il faut faire
comme par exemple la Norvège et il faut
justement se servir de nos hydrocarbures
sur notre territoire pour financer la
transition énergétique l'électrification
de nos transports parce qu'il y a un
coût à ça et il faut il faut trouver de
l'argent quelque part nous on pense qui
ont justement son exploit nos idéaux
carbure chez nous on va pouvoir avoir
justement moins trois effets de serre à
l'échelle planétaire et on va pouvoir
également financer l'électrification de
nos transports dans l'ensemble des
régions du Québec c'est pas on peut pas
demander des sacrifices aux gens sans
leur dire exactement qu'est-ce qui va se
passer comme les quatre autres parties
on pense qu'il faut donner leur juste au
quai très bien Éric merci le débat
ouvert commence on a 15 minutes une
quinzaine de minutes pour parler
d'environnement c'était la journée
mondiale aujourd'hui sans voiture la
Journée mondiale sans voiture les
transports au Québec sont responsables
de la moitié des GES comment réduire le
nombre de voitures qui augmentent deux
fois plus vite que la population du
Québec actuellement encore en 2022
sans taxer les véhicules polluants Paul
Saint-Pierre Plamondon vous commencez ce
débat ouvert vous vous êtes contre une
taxe pour les autopollants non je suis
pas contre mais à court terme je dis on
a l'obligation de donner aux gens des
options si on taxe l'achat de véhicule à
essence l'an prochain mais que les gens
ont pas plus de transport collectif et
ils n'ont pas plus de voitures
électriques en vente on appauvrit les
gens puis c'est pas très productif sur
le plan de l'envie de voter en fonction
de l'environnement on propose de doubler
les transports collectifs contraindre
les fabricants et les concessionnaires
avant des véhicules électriques avec des
cibles similaires à ce qui se fait en
Europe en Californie et on veut une
passe climat 365 dollars par année
transport illimité à travers le Québec
de manière à encourager le transport
collectif mais également une mesure
économique qui met de l'argent dans la
poche des gens Gabriel ne joue Dubois
votre taxe sur une longue va changer de
modèle de voiture on est un autre débat
mais grande caravane 5000 dollars à peu
près
que ça coûterait donc deux enfants plus
un chien la famille devra payer sa
grande caravane 5000 dollars de plus
c'est ça votre taxe mais vous dites il
faut le faire c'est le sacrifice vous
parlez de Dodge Caravan savez-vous que
le Toyota RAV4 on en vend 24 fois plus
au Québec que des doses
sera pas touché par notre plan moi je
trouve que les quatre parties dans les
dernières semaines ont beaucoup parlé
juste d'une moitié de notre plan mais
l'autre moitié est importante aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire avec ce
programme de bonus malus c'est qu'on va
réduire les prix des véhicules
électriques il va y en avoir plus dans
les concessionnaires les gens vont
attendre moins longtemps avant d'en
avoir un et oui les véhicules très
polluants sont en augmentation
épouvantable au Québec 300% de plus
depuis les années 90 ils vont coûter un
petit peu plus cher ça monsieur roi faut
le rappeler c'est pour la prochaine
voiture que les Québécois québécoises
vont acheter nous on pense que les
prochains il faut encourager les gens à
faire les bons choix pour la planète
c'est l'avenir de les enfants qui
étaient
un sujet qui est important d'abord moi
je trouve ça noble ce que propose
monsieur Nadaud Dubois d'aller plus vite
que le 37 et demi pour cent mais faut
quand même regarder les impacts sur les
citoyens quand vous dites monsieur nado
Dubois vous voulez mettre une taxe
orange de
7500 dollars sur une fourgonnette
familiale que vous voulez aussi fermer
des entreprises que vous voulez
augmenter la dette de 40% en
investissant 74 milliards mais moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu comme de
la magie c'est un peu comme si vous
étiez au pays des merveilles monsieur
nado Dubois
c'est l'enjeu du 21e siècle c'est quand
la dernière fois que tous les Québécois
ont été réunis les syndicats le patronat
les organismes communautaires la société
civile pour se dire on va se donner un
élan on va se donner un véritable projet
de société puis c'est ça qu'on propose
avec le projet écho où on est capable de
combiner l'écologie et l'économie on
n'est pas obligé de taxer les gens pour
le faire et ce qu'on a besoin de faire
c'est de se dire on va investir dans
l'éolien on va investir dans le solaire
on va investir dans l'hydrogène vert et
on va parvenir à atteindre nos objectifs
de carbone neutralité c'est ça qu'on a
besoin de faire c'est ça qu'on propose
on n'est pas obligé de parler que
d'économie puis de se donner aucune
cible crédible en environnement ou de
parler d'environnement avec des
pénalités qui vont à court terme créer
plus de problèmes probablement que de
solution on peut joindre les deux dans
un plan qui est rigoureux et qui vise
juste et nous c'est ce qu'on offre c'est
ce qu'on veut faire aux parties
québécois
passez moi l'expression on pèse sur le
gaz
c'est de dire on est tous pas une
famille de Québécois à 5000 dollars pour
acheter un v.us parce qu'ils ont besoin
de transporter leur enfant puis leur
chien on trouve que ça a pas de bon sens
et mieux mais on vaut mieux que ça nous
on veut on veut détaxer les produits
usagers c'est-à-dire que les voitures
ont déjà été taxées quand elles sont
vendues on veut même les détaxer quand
elles sont revendues parce que des gens
qui ont normalement un peu moins de
revenus qu'on trouve que au niveau
équitable c'est plus ça serait beaucoup
mieux que ces gens-là ne paient pas de
taxes sur une voiture
usagée pour ce qui est de si on veut
réduire la pollution par les transports
nous ce qu'on veut faire on propose on
veut un projet pilote à Québec on
voudrait qu'il y ait le transport en
commun gratuit pour mesurer
véritablement l'appétit pour la
population j'ai pas le tramway on est
contre le tramway mais pour le transport
en commun gratuit à Québec comme projet
pilote pour voir combien de personnes
vont abandonner leur deuxième voiture ou
même leur première voiture au profit du
transport en commun s'il y a
véritablement une appétit pour ça oui
mais je vais revenir à Monsieur Nadou tu
vois je l'ai pas entendu nous féliciter
pour le contrat qu'on a signé avec New
York ça va retirer l'équivalent d'un
million de taux des routes maintenant je
pense monsieur Nadou Dubois vous devez
une réponse au Québec vous avez dit la
taxe orange de 7500$ à vos pas
s'appliquer pour des familles de 3
enfants au Québec 85 % des familles ont
un ou deux enfants ensuite vous avez dit
la taxe orange s'appliquera pas dans
certaines régions je pense les Québécois
ont droit de savoir quelle région
j'ai répondu réplique puis après ça ce
sont les régions elles-mêmes qui vont
moduler ce programme là parce qu'on peut
pas faire du murmur mais vous savez quoi
monsieur Legault au dernier débat la
semaine passée vous avez accusé monsieur
Duhem d'avoir tiré dans Chalot durant la
pandémie mais en environnement là c'est
exactement ça que vous faites au lieu
d'encourager les Québécois québécoises
avec un projet positif vous voyez là
tout le temps que vous prenez ce soir un
million de temps que vous prenez ce soir
pour attaquer Québec solidaire au lieu
de proposer un projet positif très bien
on va lancer le plus grand chantier
depuis la Révolution tranquille du
transport en commun pour tous ces
régions pour qu'au Québec ce soit aussi
facile de se déplacer en Europe merci
qu'on est rendu là merci rapidement Paul
Saint-Pierre Plamondon et Madame Anglade
puis après je vous relance une autre
question de manière très concrète on
veut que les transports en commun soient
gratuits pour les étudiantes et pour les
personnes aînées ça ça va véritablement
encourager les gens à se déplacer puis
quand j'entends le
je dois vous dire ça ressemble à ça à la
différence à la différence que on veut
également un projet de société un projet
de société où on est capable de se
donner les moyens d'arrivée à atteindre
la carbone neutralité et ça François
Legault vous ne le proposez pas parce
que fondamentalement au fond de vous là
la lutte au changement climatique ça ne
vous habite pas ça ne vous habite pas
alors que c'est ça l'enjeu du 21e siècle
l'enjeu du XXIe siècle c'est de faire en
sorte que on soit capable de combiner
l'écologie et l'économie c'est tentant
pour des sujets importants de se pointer
du doigt moi je veux juste mentionner
deux éléments
premièrement il y a deux parties sur
cinq qui ont déposé un plan complet
chiffré sur le plan des GS ce n'est pas
le gouvernement qui pourtant avait 28
millions de dollars pour des études
qu'on a jamais vues sur le troisième
bien deuxième éléphant dans la pièce
chaque année l'équipe Québécois et les
Québécoises voit leurs impôts partir
vers Ottawa et se sont plus de 2
milliards de dollars versés au
pétrolière de l'Alberta en cadeau puis
en subvention donc si on est sérieux à
propos de l'environnement oui on va
faire un plan qu'on va faire notre part
mais on va également faire
l'indépendance du Québec pour que cesse
ces contributions
dans la pièce le troisième lien je pense
qu'il est là
depuis le début de la campagne bon
je lance le débat puis tout le monde a
le droit de parole je le rappelle je
lance le débat monsieur le groupe est-ce
que des études où il y a pas d'études
d'abord actuellement en Québec et les
vits
qui est en cours parce qu'on a annoncé
il y a un an qu'on va faire un tunnel de
centre-ville à centre-ville c'est la
meilleure façon de faire la promotion
combien
d'avoir un lien pense pas qu'un pont qui
détruirait l'île d'Orléans
c'est la bonne idée on a besoin d'un
lien on propose un tunnel monsieur Lego
c'est qui qui fait l'étude puis combien
ça coûte votre cette étude là donc vous
parlez
[Musique]
que je promets aujourd'hui mais monsieur
Lego on évolue tout le monde évolue oui
vous avez évolué vous avez abandonné les
gens de la région
vous savez même pas qu'il fallait bien
fini conclué
aujourd'hui la une Journal de Québec là
c'est que le compte Québec pour être
démoli je sais pas si vous avez vu ça
après ça la semaine passée j'ai parlé à
monsieur Legault j'ai demandé s'il y
avait une effectivement une proposition
que deux voix sur le Pont Pierre Laporte
près de fermer il m'a dit non en cas de
Radio-Canada prouvé que oui il y a eu
une édition il y a même des échanges de
courriels et aujourd'hui nous dit qu'il
y a ici sécuritaire je ne fais pas peur
au monde pourquoi ils ont enlevé toutes
les équipements sur le pont monsieur
Lego monsieur Lego moi j'en ai une
petite je vous jure je vous donne les
paroles à tout le monde si votre étude
montrent que c'est un pont la meilleure
option est-ce que vous dites tant pis je
vois quand même en tunnel écoutez
détruit le paysage d'une des plus belles
villes au monde les pilons
détruire l'île d'Orléans avec une
autoroute que c'est pas une bonne idée
ça l'était avant
monsieur Legault c'est que peu importe
que la science vous dit vous avez décidé
que vous allez dans une d'une direction
ça fait quatre ans ça fait 4 ans qui
sont au gouvernement il y a aucune étude
qui a été rendue publique il y en a des
études il y en a des études qui ont été
faites mais on ne les voit pas on nous
les cache puis c'est ça l'enjeu par
rapport au troisième lien c'est que
personne ne sait au centre moi là moi je
vais vous dire une affaire moi je suis
ingénieur de formation des plans puis
des devis de j'en ai vu dans ma vie j'en
ai vu dans ma vie il y a aucun plan
aucun devis qui a été présenté au bout
de quatre ans nous ce qu'on veut c'est
faire les études rapidement pour qu'on
trouve des solutions à la à Québec
je veux juste préciser le monsieur Lego
vous avez dit que c'était un projet qui
est politique et que étude poétude pour
des raisons politiques vous alliez le
faire c'est ce que vous avez déclaré
donc un moment donné étude pour études
il procède pour des raisons
électoralistes et à tous les gens
traversent le Québec ça vous dit à quel
point les décisions de la CAQ sont peu
fondées sur l'intérêt public et pendant
ce temps-là il y a des projets de
transport structurant dans l'est de
Montréal qui ont pas avancé pendant
quatre ans il y a un pont à Tadoussac
pour lequel on a déjà 14 étapes et
laquelle 14 études depuis 1973 puis vous
en voulez une autre pour celui-là mais
le troisième lien par exemple sur pas de
problème 8 10 12 milliards c'est parti
que les études que vous avez que vous
cachez au Québécois vous voulez pas les
montrer parce qu'ils sont périmés parce
que c'était avant la crise Center vous
avez dit ça on a entendu ça les études
qui ont été faites le tramway elles sont
aussi périmées parce qu'il y a 30% moins
d'usagers des autobus à Québec
présentement est-ce que vous allez
remettre le projet de tramway sur la
glace en attendant le renouvellement de
nouvelles études ou si ça c'est pas
pareil parce que le tramway vous êtes
pauvre puis alors que le troisième bien
vous voulez faire l'anglais la
population les études sur le troisième
lien c'était un lien à l'est avec cette
autre projet avec 6 voies nous ce qu'on
propose c'est un tunnel avec quatre voix
dont deux voix aux heures de pointe qui
sont pour le transport collectif plutôt
que de prendre 30 minutes ça va prendre
10 minutes pour ce qui est du tramway
ben écoutez d'une grande ville comme
Québec là on a donc les études
importantes la mise à jour post pandémie
le temps file sur ce sur ce thème et je
veux vous parler
d'Hydro-Québec des barrages monsieur
Lego vous avez l'ancien campagne ça
prend des barrages est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord ou pas vous avez dit non dans
certains pour certains d'entrevue madame
en garde vous vous dites on a pas besoin
de nouveaux barrages on a besoin de plus
d'électricité puis ça passe par l'éolien
ça passe par le solaire ça passe par
l'économie d'énergie qu'on fait ici au
Québec puis ça passe par l'hydrogène
vert partout sur la planète on se
transforme sauf au Québec monsieur Lego
il va nous parler de barrage mais ça
c'était il y a déjà plusieurs années là
dans le siècle dernier aujourd'hui ou
21e siècle lorsqu'on propose comme
projet avec l'éolien c'est vraiment un
projet d'une génération c'est ça qu'on
propose sur le groupe barrage absolument
écoutez c'est mathématique si on regarde
les plans l'un des trois qui sont ici
c'est impossible avec
l'efficacité énergétique et l'éolien
parce que l'éolien c'est intermittent ça
prend des barrages ou du nucléaire nous
on dit Déborah maintenant parle
d'hydrogène vers ça prend beaucoup
d'électricité mais pas capable de nous
dire où elle va prendre l'électricité
pour l'hydrogène vert ça marche pas son
affaire si on avait écouté si on avait
écouté monsieur Legault quand le temps
d'investir dans l'éolien on l'aurait pas
fait parce qu'il nous disait que c'était
trop cher si on avait écouté monsieur
Legault quand c'était le temps
d'investir dans la bourse du carbone on
l'aurait pas fait parce que il nous
disait qu'il croyait pas vraiment
là-dedans il faut anticiper faut voir ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui dans
l'hydrogène vers là c'est partout sur la
planète en Europe au Danemark en
Angleterre en Allemagne ils investissent
de manière massive et se transforme et
c'est là qu'on doit embarquer on doit
embarquer maintenant vos potes barrages
c'est à dire que Monsieur le goût promet
des barrages mais on sait pas sur quelle
rivière ça nous le dit jamais vous on
sait pas ils vont être construits mais
vous vous êtes français nous on a un
plan puis là-dessus je suis d'accord
avec Monsieur plamondo nos plans nous là
qui ont été modélisés par une ferme
spécialisée mon plan là il est approuvé
par huit experts indépendants ça c'est 8
experts de plus que vous mais ce plan là
dit c'est qu'on a pas besoin de nouveau
barrage pour rappel donc monsieur le
goût les gens ont le choix soit ils
croient monsieur troisième lien soit il
croit les experts je pense qu'ils vont
choisir pour pouvoir les excès
moi je crois qu'il faut diversifier nos
sources d'énergie on le sait qu'on va
avoir besoin de plus d'énergie c'est
pour ça que la partie conservateur on
est les seuls qui sont favorables à
l'exploitation de notre gaz mais on est
aussi favorable à développer plus de
filières hydroélectriques évidemment ok
environnemental je vais gruger sur le
temps les barrages ça peut être
nécessaire mais c'est pas démonter pour
l'instant mais ça ne doit pas être un
substitut à un plan en matière de
changement climatique et c'est ça que
Monsieur LEGO a cette paire passer les
barrages comme si c'était un plan
vis-à-vis les changements climatiques
je vous change de sujet les vous allez
voir une carte apparaître les clins
miniers ça a doublé ça a doublé au
Québec et ça touche des milieux naturels
des milieux de villégiature laximon lac
des plages ou taway Laurentides
les préfets vous demandent monsieur
Legault disent faites un moratoire il y
a pas d'acceptabilité sociale partout
oui faire le Québec la batterie de
l'Amérique du Nord mais le prix à payer
est-ce que c'est de détruire des milieux
auxquels on tient
d'abord je vais être très clair il y a
effectivement des milieux où il y a de
l'acceptabilité sociale puis il y a des
milieux où il y a pas d'acceptabilité
sociale quand il y a pas d'acceptabilité
sociale il y aura pas d'exploitation
donc c'est clair on va exploiter là où
le milieu est d'accord pour qu'on
travaille dans certaines mines est-ce
que là-dessus il y a en ce moment
monsieur roi un beau minier au Québec
puis c'est pas seulement une mauvaise
nouvelle parce qu'il y a de ce minerai
là qu'on a besoin pour la transition
écologique mais ça peut pas se faire
n'importe comment nous on va répondre
présent à la demande des élus municipaux
des gouvernements de proximité qui
disent là ça peut pas se faire n'importe
comment il faut bien moratoire
temporaire sur les nouveaux clins dans
les secteurs villégiature dans les
secteurs habités le temps qu'on se donne
au Québec un nouveau pack social minier
pour que ça se fasse comme du monde je
veux je veux l'accès acceptabilité
sociale environnement c'est exactement
ça acceptabilité sociale mais il faut
collaborer il faut collaborer avec les
il faut pas se poser avec les vies puis
imposer des choix très bien bon je vais
d'autres sujets d'environnement mais ça
sera pour un autre débat parce que des
il y a un sujet qui préoccupe les gens
la Réserve fédérale hier dit les taux
d'intérêt élevé le préparez-vous
messieurs dames on en a pour longtemps
peut-être jusqu'à 5%
coût de la vie économie
il y a un sujet qui vous préoccupe
surtout l'inflation le pouvoir d'achat
l'inflation me gruges
parce que
les pinceaux de vraiment monter parce
qu'on a pas beaucoup pour vivre
cher l'alimentation les prix cette
orbitants ils ont tout augmentent
les prix des logements ne sont pas
d'aller même pour payer un 3 et demi
et jeunes aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'ils
vont faire une maison un jour faudrait
que ça sur place ici à bientôt
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire pour baisser
l'inflation
l'argent qu'on gagne suffit pas
comment pensez-vous alléger les phares
de financier des familles québécoises
c'est peut-être la question que vous
avez la plus entendue sur la route de la
campagne électorale Paul Saint-Pierre
Platon d'abord chacun à 35 secondes pour
répondre tous les partis ici promettent
soit une baisse d'impôts soit une baisse
de taxe il y a que le Parti québécois
pour dire on ne donnera pas de cadeau
plus riche on hypothécropole notre
avenir mais on donne le soutien le plus
généreux de tous les parties ici pour
ceux qui gagnent en 0 et 50 000 une
remise de 1200$ d'ici la fin de l'année
en 50000 et 80000 750 dollars
essentiellement on prend les surplus de
l'État en raison de l'inflation on leur
redonne à ceux qui ont de la misère à
rejoindre des deux bouts mais sans
s'attaquer au service public et sans
faire de cadeaux au plus riche ce qui
est malheureusement le défaut des autres
propositions
il y a des familles qui arrivent pas il
y a des retraités qui ont des petites
pensions qui sont mal pris et contraire
ce que dit Monsieur Saint-Pierre
Plamondon c'est la CAQ en 2022 le
maintenant qui offre le plus d'argent
dans le portefeuille on veut donner 4 à
600 dollars au mois de décembre à tous
ceux qui gagnent moins de 100000 puis on
veut donner 2000 dollars de plus à
partir de 2022 au 70 ans et plus puis
après on va baisser les impôts merci
Eric dum 35 secondes mais nous le Parti
conservateur du Québec on est le parti
qui offre les plus importantes baisse
d'impôts de tous les partis politiques à
l'heure actuelle et on propose également
de suspendre la taxe sur l'essence
justement pour donner du ripi aux
familles du Québec pour que ça soit le
gouvernement qui se sert la ceinture
dans ses dépenses plutôt que les
familles du Québec qui souffrent
présentement nos bases d'impôts sont
tellement généreuses pour une famille
par exemple avec deux enfants qui
gagnent 80000 dollars c'est plus de 3000
dollars de baisse d'impôts annuellement
récurrent je pense que c'est le genre de
politique que les gens ont besoin pour
pouvoir arriver parce que sinon on y
arrivera pas et c'est de loin le sujet
dont on parle le plus mais depuis le
début de la campagne aussi Dominique
Anglade 35 secondes mais à tous ceux qui
nous écoutent vous l'avez entendu dans
le vox pop il y en a qui doivent choisir
entre payer l'épicerie payer le logement
puis ça crée énormément d'incertitudes
puis d'angoisse nous ce qu'on veut c'est
retourner l'argent dans les poches des
familles 5000 dollars par famille
concrètement c'est pas un chèque qui va
être envoyé une fois c'est quelque chose
qui va être récurrent année après année
l'autre volet qui est hyper important
c'est que la seule chose qui augmente
pas là c'est le revenu de nos aînés
c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin d'avoir une
allocation pour aînée de 2000 dollars
par année année après année pas un
chèque ça vient chaque année dans les
poches de nausées merci Gabriel Nadaud
Dubois conclusion 35 secondes c'est une
question en effet qui nous est souvent
posée qu'on se promène qu'on rencontre
des gens sur le terrain puis il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire pour aider
les gens à se sortir de cette crise du
coût de la vie je dois vous nommer nos
deux priorités d'abord il faut donner un
congé de TVQ sur les biens essentiels ça
veut dire pas tes vécu à l'épicerie à la
pharmacie au restaurant sur les
vêtements ou pour faire des réparations
par exemple de sa voiture ça c'est plus
de 1000 dollars d'économies pour une
famille au Québec et la deuxième affaire
à faire c'est réglé la crise du logement
c'est le premier poste de dépenses des
familles on réglera pas la crise du coût
de la vie si on règle pas la crise du
logement merci il y a donc deux camps
vous l'avez dit ceux qui proposent des
baisses d'impôts monsieur Legault madame
anglaise monsieur dum et ceux qui sont
contre Monsieur Saint-Pierre Plamondon
et Monsieur Nadaud Dubois ben si les
impôts monsieur Legault c'est vous qui
lancez le bloc ouvert ce n'est pas aussi
réduire les services publics bon d'abord
nous ce qui est le plus important ce
sont les montants ponctuels qu'on donne
en 2022 4 à 600 dollars en décembre puis
2000 dollars pour les personnes de 70
ans et plus les baisses d'impôts
commencent l'année prochaine sont moins
élevés que le Parti libéral est parti
conservateur parce qu'on pense qu'il
faut agir à court terme maintenant
économiquement là on a besoin de
soulager les contribuables de donner un
institatif au travail on est dans le
plafond au Canada en Amérique du Nord
pour les impôts vraiment
plus importantes que les baisses
proposées par la CAQ est-ce que ce n'est
pas maître de l'huile sur le feu avec
cette spirale inflationniste parce que
vous touchez à des gens quand même qui
ont des bons revenus
non ça l'est pas parce que on a besoin
d'avoir des gens qui puissent vraiment
faire face au coup de la vie mais
l'autre manière dont on a approché le
problème c'est vraiment de se dire que
les gens de la classe moyenne qu'on
diminue leur impôts mais que les gens
qui sont capables de contribuer
davantage les gens qui gagnent plus de
300000 dollars l'argent qui dort dans
les paradis fiscaux l'argent que les
grandes banques ou les grandes sociétés
d'assurance peuvent donner qui soient
capables de contribuer on est le parti
qui fait en sorte que on descend les
impôts pour la classe moyenne mais on
demande aussi à ceux qui sont capables
d'en payer davantage de faire leur part
puis c'est comme ça qu'on a une société
qui soit juste puisqu'il est équitable
monsieur nado Dubois on vous a reproché
de ratisser pas mal large avec votre
notion de riche avec des biens qui
peuvent valoir oui un million mais après
une vie complète d'économie est-ce que
vous ratissez pas effectivement assez
large moi je pense que le 5 % le plus
riche au Québec on les moyens de
contribuer un peu plus puissant ça ça va
être bon pour 100% des Québécois
québécois ça va nous donner des
meilleures des meilleurs hôpitaux des
meilleurs CHSLD on va pouvoir investir
pour vrai dans l'environnement et ça va
nous permettre de baisser les factures
de tout le monde au Québec on va faire
baisser la facture du dentiste parce
qu'on va mettre en place une assurance
dentaire publique et universelle ça
coûte un bras à l'échelle dentiste on va
faire baisser la facture de la rentrée
scolaire on va baisser les tarifs de
transport en commun de 50 % pour faire
ça ça prend des investissements ça prend
de l'argent et oui moi je suis pas gêné
dire on va aller chercher cet argent là
chez le 5% le plus riche au Québec les
quatre autres parties ont pas ce courage
là moi je pense qu'on est alors allez-y
mais moi ce que je veux dire c'est que
oui on est on offre des bases d'impôts
mais contrairement aux parties libéral
et à la CAQ on veut pas aller piger ça
dans les poches la prochaine génération
j'étais très surpris pour pas dire déçu
quand j'ai vu monsieur Lecourt manquer
d'équité envers les générations en
allant piger l'argent dans le fond des
générations je trouve ça
particulièrement irresponsable on a déjà
un problème d'équité intergénérationnels
on est déjà en train d'appauvrir la
prochaine génération puis vous en
ajoutez une couche en allant essayez
d'acheter la prochaine élection en
hypothéquant l'avenir de la prochaine
génération j'ai pas trouvé ça que
c'était la plus brillante des idées
madame Anglade c'est beau de baisser les
impôts mais quand après ça vous dites
que vous voulez augmenter le déficit de
façon considérable vous aussi c'est une
façon indirecte de pelleter le problème
sur le dos de la prochaine génération on
est les seuls qui proposons des baisses
d'impôts qui sont responsables
c'est-à-dire que on va le piger dans
l'argent qu'on a actuellement plutôt que
d'hypothéquer la prochaine génération
combien de fonctionnaires vous mettez à
la porte parce que vos coupures sont
assez élevées on propose essentiellement
ce que monsieur Legault proposait il y a
4 ans qui n'a pas rempli comme promesse
on voudrait réduire de 5000 le nombre
d'employés de l'État cela étant dit on
veut pas congédier personnes parce que
vous savez que notre fonction publique
au Québec elle est vieillissante on
voudrait fonctionner par attrition donc
on voudrait mais on veut réduire la
taille de l'État contrairement à
Monsieur le goût on va pas dire une
chose pour faire le contraire si on est
élu juste pour des fins de rigueur là
les parties qui promettent des baisses
d'impôts c'est réduire les revenus de
l'État et mettez-vous dans une situation
par exemple de récession hypothétique
ça veut dire un autre cycle d'austérité
pour les travailleurs du public de la
santé c'est un aller simple vers le
stérilité et c'est un cadeau au plus
riche pour ce qui est de la baisse de
taxes que Québec solidaire propose c'est
peut-être que une contribution 300 400
dollars pour quelqu'un qui gagne 30 000
mais pour quelqu'un qui gagne 300000 par
exemple c'est un bon 222 dollars si vous
l'avez dans un restaurant de luxe vous
achetez des choses de luxe la remise au
plus riche est beaucoup plus grande que
celle à ceux qui en ont besoin donc nous
au Parti québécois on dit
concentrons-nous sur les gens et les
familles qui ont de la misère à
rejoindre les deux bouts pas de cadeaux
au plus riche et surtout pas à
s'attaquer hypothéquer nos services
publics
va devoir répondre du fait que quand
lorsqu'on regarde les il veut faire des
révisions de programme dans son cadre
financier va nous dire où est-ce qu'il
veut aller chercher les montants
d'argent par rapport aux prévisions de
programme mais je suis d'accord avec
Monsieur Paul Saint-Pierre pas Mondon
quand il dit on est on doit aussi faire
en sorte que les gens qui soient plus
riches contribuent c'est pour ça que
notre programme on a justement ça on va
demander aux gens qui sont capables de
contribuer davantage de plus de 300000
dollars de le faire ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle une véritable équité oui on est
capable de baisser les impôts pour la
classe moyenne et demander aux gens qui
sont capables de contribuer d'en faire
plus c'est ça la justice sociale
également
on avait un écart de richesse de 16%.
c'était comme ça depuis 10 ans avec
l'Ontario on aurait dû ça à 13%. donc
faut attirer plus d'investissements les
entreprises mais moi j'ai une question
pour Monsieur Nadaud Dubois qui a dit je
le cite il y a des secteurs de notre
économie qui certainement doivent
décroître donc je pense les Québécois on
le doit de savoir quelles entreprises
dans quelle région vous voulez les
fermer dans quelle région vous voulez
fermer des entreprises c'est ce que vous
avez dit
c'est pas ce que j'ai dit Monsieur
legodiale change le secteur du pétrole
le secteur du gaz les raffineries on est
en 2022 c'est secteur là ils vont se
transformer mais oui ils vont être plus
fragiles la demande en pétrole et en gaz
vont plafonner au Québec il va plafonner
dans le monde c'est une tendance
mondiale
1994 la nouvelle économie c'est
l'économie verte nous notre vision se
développements économique c'est de
encourager les secteurs d'avenir et
accompagner dans cette
transitions
arrêtez de sortir les décorations dans
le win arrêtez de faire peur au monde
l'API des merveilles
du sondage mainstream sondage justement
sur l'exploitation du gaz naturel au
Québec ils ont demandé au Québec une
bonne idée d'exporter notre gaz naturel
vers l'Europe pour remplacer le gaz
russe il y a 60% des Québécois qui
disent oui vous êtes quatre parties à
dire non vous êtes en train de dire non
à une industrie vous avez déjà été en
faveur monsieur legouv vous promettiez
sur vous avez cru un chapitre entier
dans votre livre cap sur un Québec
gagnant pour l'action puis aujourd'hui
vous voulez plus rien savoir et là vous
êtes en train de faire poursuivre vous
mettez le Québec à risque de devoir des
milliards de dollars et des entreprises
à qui vous aviez donné des droits et
vous êtes en train de les retirer
unilatéralement monsieur Legault à quoi
vous jouez
vous vous l'exploiter du gaz puis du
pétrole nous on veut développer
l'électricité incluant des barrages
contrairement aux trois parties qui sont
ici très bien vraiment vous écoutez tous
ces messieurs discuter et à la fin de la
journée là aujourd'hui un éléphant dans
la pièce de point de vue économique puis
le descend dans la pièce s'appelle la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre il s'appelle le
fait que on n'a pas suffisamment de
personnes puis au début c'était un enjeu
qui était économique mais il est devenu
social parce qu'on n'a pas de monde dans
nos écoles parce qu'on n'a pas de monde
un service de la santé puis monsieur
Lego vous disiez en 2018 on va en
prendre moins c’était votre slogan on va
en prendre moins puis on va prendre soin
puis la réalité c'est que dans les
quatre dernières années on a pris moins
de pharmacies moins d'infirmières moins
de préposés au bénéficiaires et le
résultat c'est que on a moins de soins
et moins de service et la population le
ressent partout partout l'enjeu de la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre frappe de plein
fouet on parle d'économie là ça fait 12
minutes qu'on débat présentement de
l'enjeu de la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
il y a rien qui a été fait de manière
concrète pour la régler le problème
les salaires ont jamais augmenté aussi
vite qu'actuellement les travailleurs
sont contents maintenant la solution là
augmenter la productivité des
entreprises
requalifier ceux qui étaient par exemple
dans le secteur du détail c'est pas vrai
que la seule solution c'est
l'immigration ça vous intéresse pas de
protéger le français ça vous intéresse
pas au sujet si je peux me permettre le
sujet c'est le coût de la vie j'aimerais
qu'on y revienne
parlons d'éléphants dans la pièce il y
en a un que je veux nommer les
pétrolières ont fait 29 milliards de
profits dans les 6 derniers mois qu'on a
pu mesurer ça ça veut dire que l'argent
des Québécoises à les Québécois là elle
est siphonnée à la pompe par des gens
qui volent qui nous volent c'est un
cartel qui agit en violation de toutes
les règles de concurrence et à ma
connaissance le Parti québécois et le
seul parti à vouloir s'attaquer à ces
pétrolières en disant on va imposer vos
surprofis puis on va exercer un contrôle
sur la concurrence parce que c'est du
vol et on peut pas imprimer des fonds
publics pour que sa transite quelques
secondes dans le portefeuille des
Québécois pour ensuite s'en aller dans
les paradis fiscaux dans des compagnies
multinationales
est-ce que c'est possible de taxer les
pétrolières au Québec il y a un prix
Nobel si on taxe les pétrolières ils
vont répercuter son prix
ça a fonctionné monsieur Legault le prêt
à la pompe en Ontario moins cher
pourquoi vous faites pas ça pourquoi
vous donnez pas un breaks
à 600 dollars puis laisser la liberté
aux gens ça vous dit quelque chose la
liberté
que d'imposer ça se fait Royaume-Uni
mais il y a un prix Nobel qui a 5 jours
et sorti pour dire c'est ça qu'il faut
faire donc avant de dire que c'est
impossible voyons ce qu'ils se font sur
fait de mieux à l'étranger sur les
experts sur les pétrolières madame
Anglade puis monsieur Dubois ensuite
l'enjeu fondamental honnêtement là c'est
pas d'aller
parce que l'enjeu fondamental en train
de passer à côté monsieur Roy le l'enjeu
économique essentiel aujourd'hui
monsieur Legault il aime beaucoup se
comparer à l'Ontario mais on a créé
trois fois moins il a créé trois fois
moins d'emplois que l'Ontario mais c'est
mais c'est vrai monsieur Legault et en
plus en plus dans tous les secteurs
d'énergie il est obsédé par le par
l'Ontario mais la réalité c'est que la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre c'est le frein
essentiel qu'on a aujourd'hui partout
les vont vous le dire d'un point de vue
économique ça ne tient pas la route
pénurie de main d'oeuvre on fait quoi
mais nous on pense qu'il faut d'abord
ramener les aînés qui veulent travailler
on veut que les gens de 60 ans et plus
puissent avoir des crédits d'impôts
supplémentaires pour venir même c'est
juste un jour deux jours trois jours ça
va être du mentorat ça va être
l'expertise qu'on a besoin ça va être
également un une socialisation pour ces
personnes là nous on pense qu'il faut
vraiment investir sur nos aînés Gabriel
du bon fait quoi pénurie de main
d'oeuvre on fait quoi l'immigration
c'est pas la solution magique à la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre mais c'est une
partie de la solution nos régions ont
besoin de renfort moi quand je me
promène depuis le début de la campagne
c'est les entreprises mais c'est aussi
les travailleurs travailleuses tout le
monde le dit c'est aussi le secteur
public on a besoin de bras on a besoin
de renfort quand on accueille plus
d'immigrants d'immigrants on gonfle
notre population active ça fait en sorte
que plus de monde à l'ouvrage ça va nous
donner des meilleurs services publics au
Québec moi quand je me promène dans les
régions c'est ça que j'entends am le
bout du monde en renfort puis nous on va
le faire par Saint-Pierre Plamondon
pénurie de main d'oeuvre les économistes
de référence disent que d'augmenter les
seuils ça ne compte pas la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre par exemple en Ontario ils
ont accueilli un million de personnes en
disant sont toujours en pénurie de main
d'oeuvre ce qu'on peut faire par contre
c'est augmenter la participation au
travail notamment en permettant aux
parents d'avoir une place garantie en
CPE c'est ce qu'on propose augmenter la
participation du travail des aînés on
offre une baisse du taux d'imposition
pour les aînés les derniers éléments
parce que on passe toujours à côté de ce
sujet-là il y a des régions au Québec où
on investit moins en infrastructure où
on investit moins en termes d'économie
c'est vrai pour l'Est du Québec la côte
nord l'Abitibi laisse de Montréal on est
le seul parti avoir mesuré ce déficit
d'investissement et on va très bien le
dire on va rendre justice pour que ce
soit écrit je reviens au coût de la vie
et une dernière table dernier tour de
table sur l'accès à la propriété on
vient de comparer avec l'Ontario là
c'est pas reluisant pour le Québec il y
a 59 9% des Québécois qui sont
propriétaires en Ontario c'est 68 là à
peu près donc on a un grave que le
comment faire pour améliorer l'accès la
propriété des gens qui nous écoutent qui
disent on peut plus acheter ce logo mais
la seule façon d'y arriver c'est de
créer de la richesse comme on a fait
contrairement à ce que dit Madame
anglais on a réduit notre écart
l'Ontario il faut créer des emplois
mieux payés aujourd'hui le défi c'est
créer des emplois c'est de créer des
emplois bien payés mieux payés c'est
comme ça qu'on va réduire notre écart de
richesse on va donner le moyen au
Québécois de s'acheter une maison de
s'acheter un condo c'est ça la façon
accès à la propriété voyez-vous vous
avez posé une question très claire sur
l'accès à la propriété sur le logement
et monsieur Legault ne répond pas à la
question parce qu'il y a nié ce problème
là pendant l'essentiel de son mandat la
crise du logement et la crise de l'accès
à la propriété là c'est les deux faces
d'une même médaille il faut agir sur les
deux plans construire plus de logements
sociaux et abordables limiter les
hausses de loyer abusives et lutter
contre la spéculation la surenchère qui
est en train de priver toute une
génération de l'accès à la propriété
accès à la propriété
cette question était très spécifique
Axel appropriété il y a plein de
personnes qui nous écoutent aujourd'hui
qui ont acheté qui ont des faits des
demandes pour acheter des maisons 14
fois 15 fois 16 fois on peut réussir à
acheter une maison nous on propose très
concrètement d'abolir la taxe de
bienvenue de compenser 100% les villes
par rapport à ça puis de faire en sorte
que s'ils veulent utiliser l'oreillette
ils veulent râper qu'on l'augmente
jusqu'à 50000 dollars ça très
concrètement ça va aider les gens qui
veulent acheter des propriétés c'est ça
la réponse à votre question à la
propriété nous aussi on pense qu'il faut
qu'effectivement avec la taxe de
bienvenue particulièrement pour les
jeunes familles soit abolies qu'on
compense les villes évidemment mais avec
la hausse des taux d'intérêt puis la
baisse du prix des maisons il y a les
jeunes n'auront pas plus accès à la
propriété le SEPA les deux vases font en
sorte qu'il y a pas de il y a pas de
solution magique parce que si les taux
d'intérêt côté mais le prix des maisons
diminue il y aura pas plus la
possibilité d'accéder à la propriété
nous si je peux me permettre on veut
créer un crédit d'impôt pour les
premiers acheteurs en fait l'augmenter
mais c'est l'offre et la demande donc
ici il y a des parties qui veulent 50
000 70 80 000 augmenter les seuils l'an
prochain si c'est ça le seuil on n'aura
pas de nouveau logement là donc c'est
l'offre et la demande aussi qu'il faut
qu'il faut considérer on va en parler
tout à l'heure de l'immigration qu'on
reviendra puis vous direz ce que vous
voulez sur l'immigration effectivement
on pourra revenir sur la les liens qu'on
fait ou pas avec la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre thème autre sujet de
préoccupation des gens dans tous les
sondages la santé
en amont le système de santé doit être
amélioré à tous les niveaux un rôle
comme sur une crevaison plus trop
longtemps
[Musique]
et puis j'ai vu que les infirmières
étaient aboutissent je travaille à
l'urgence
si tu veux avoir un service médical
c'est compliqué si tu veux voir un
médecin
c'est encore plus compliqué
j'ai appelé pour prendre un rendez-vous
on m'a dit que je suis orpheline parce
que mon métier famille est à la retraite
moi ça fait 7 ans que j'ai pas de
médecin de famille donc c'est toujours
un problème de toujours de trouver un
médecin de famille et ça c'est pas
facile
on vend que de médecins puis
d'infirmière mais ils encouragent pas de
travailler là comment vous allez aider à
gérer la crise dans les hôpitaux en ce
moment
alors vous connaissez mieux que nous ces
questions là qu'on vous pose quand vous
allez circuler dans la population
rituelle d'abord vous avez 35 secondes
chacun iridienne le premier mais pour
nous il faut additionner la contribution
du secteur privé on croit que c'est
important de garder l'assurance
universelle publique c'est-à-dire que
notre carte d'assurance maladie va
continuer à payer pour nos soins de
santé mais si le gouvernement si l'État
n'est pas capable de fournir des soins
dans des délais raisonnables la personne
doit faire comme dans un paquet de pays
européen avoir la possibilité d'aller
dans un hôpital ou une clinique privée
et c'est sa carte d'assurance maladie
qui va payer pour ses soins et même
mieux que ça si les le privé capable de
le faire moins cher que le public elle
peut y aller même avant les délais il
peut y aller directement donc c'est
vraiment d'additionner la contribution
du privé pour merci Paul St Pierre
Plamondon l'enjeu c'est qu'on n'écoute
pas les travailleurs dans le domaine de
la santé on les respecte pas
faut les écouter et nous disent de
meilleures conditions de travail mettre
fin au temps supplémentaire obligatoire
et à des conditions de travail peu
flexibles mais tu fais également aux
agences privées et on est passé de 200
millions à 1 milliard par année qu'on
claque là-dedans sans aucun résultat
nous on croit une première ligne forte
pas juste à travers l'acte du médecin
mais à travers la contribution de tous
les professionnels de la santé pour
avoir une santé qui est accessible à
tous à travers nos CLSC Gabriel Nadaud
Dubois 35 secondes je pense que les
Québécois québécoises ont été
désillusionnés par des promesses
clinquantes qui ont été faits par le
passé par bien des partis politiques
nous on veut revenir à la base là-bas
c'est quoi partir de ce qui fonctionne
dans notre système de santé et puis
l'améliorer les CLSC ça fonctionne pour
les refinancer faut en faire une vraie
porte d'entrée le 8 en 1 ça fonctionne
faut le brancher sur le système il faut
mettre le cap vers la prise en charge
vers la maison et pour faire tout ça il
y a un passage obligé ramenez le monde
dans notre système de santé ça ça passe
par des bon conditions de travail enfin
pour les soignants du Québec moi je
pense qu'il mérite merci François
Legault oui
on est hérité d'un système de santé qui
était malade ensuite on a eu la pandémie
depuis 2 ans et demi et malgré ça on
arrive sans quelques mois à former 10000
préposés au bénéficiaires on a réussi à
ce qui est 300 000 Québécois de plus
qu'a accès à un groupe de médecine de
famille puis Christian Dubé a déposé un
plan complet évidemment ça prend trois
ans mais des infirmières donc il y a
personne ici qui peut faire de magie
mais il faut y aller graduellement puis
il faut décentraliser ce qui te plaît
merci Dominique Anglade conclusion 35
secondes moi je me dresser au 1 million
de Québécois qui ont pas de médecine de
famille on n'a pas le droit de baisser
les bras on a la responsabilité de
trouver des moyens pour vous permettre
d'avoir un médecin de famille surtout
les personnes qui ont deux maladies
chroniques qui vivent avec des enjeux de
présenter et aussi des enjeux de santé
mentale qui sont importants qui sont
répandues partout dans notre système
mais il faut également qu'on prenne soin
de notre monde puis prendre soin de
notre monde ça veut dire que il faut
arrêter le temps supplémentaire
obligatoire il faut l'éliminer puis
faire en sorte qu'on est des conditions
de travail acceptables pour toutes nos
professionnelles de la santé merci
Madame anglaise le débat ouvert commence
comment ça se fait que ça prend deux
semaines pour avoir un rendez-vous avec
un pneumologue ou privé deux semaines et
322 jours au public ça c'est 46 semaines
est-ce que plus de privés ce serait pas
une option qu'on devrait regarder
premier Gabriel ado Dubois vous lancez
le bal du dépôt-vente la présence du
privé dans le système de santé augmente
d'année en année au Québec une
augmentation de 52% en 40 donc si le
privé en santé ça marchait on le saurait
ce qu'on voit
les agences privées de placement ça
marche pas les CHSLD privé ça marche pas
donc ce dessus du même et monsieur
Legault propose c'est de continuer à
privatiser plus nous ce qu'on veut c'est
réglé enfin les problèmes de notre
système public puis on a dans notre
équipe Mélissa généreux le docteur Yves
Bonnier vigé la docteur Isabelle Leblanc
3 personnes qui demain matin pourraient
être ministre de la santé parce qu'ils
connaissent la réalité du terrain c'est
pas des gestionnaires c'est du monde du
terrain qui fait l'appliquer les
solutions qui viennent du terrain je
pense que c'est par là qu'il faut
commencer en santé au Québec c'est
socialiste fonctionnait en matière de
santé monsieur le 12 bois on le saurait
ça fait 40 ans qu'on a des ministres de
la Santé qui se promène avec des
structures puis qui changent toutes les
structures et pourtant jamais on a eu
des problèmes jamais on a eu un système
aussi inefficace que celui qu'on a à
l'heure actuelle moi je pense monsieur
Nadou Dubois il faut amener là on peut
bien jouer encore des structures une
autre fois ou deux autres fois mais la
réalité c'est que ça prend de la
concurrence vous le savez comme moi un
monopole peu importe même si le public
ou privé un monopole ça ne fonctionne
pas puis au Québec malheureusement c'est
les patients du Québec qui payent
présentement pour ce monopole inefficace
il faut emmener avec dépendre il faut
prendre
vous savez que pour les choses
essentielles je vous donne un exemple
bien concret un médecin présentement
Québec là il ne peut pas pratiquer et au
public et au privé c'est illégal c'est
100 % un ou 100 % 0 au Québec on a un
système à deux vitesses présentement
nous on veut un système à une vitesse
parce que présentement les autres riches
peuvent y aller mais nous on veut que
tout le monde puisse avoir accès au
système de santé privé
bon il manque 6 milliards de dollars par
année en santé au Québec François
Legault avec son fédéralisme de gain
dans le Canada nous avait promis d'aller
les chercher il a demandé par quatre
fois puis maintenant Justin Trudeau se
déplace même pas il prend même plus la
peine il répond à 24 heures non donc
s'il manque 6 milliards ce sont des
sommes importantes et notre relation
avec le fédéral elle doit être nommée si
on décidait nous-mêmes de nos budgets
qu'on prenaient nos propres décisions
comme québécoise et québécois on serait
pas pris à quémander comme toutes les
provinces canadiennes des sommes aussi
majeurs que 6 milliards de dollars la
seule solution à ça c'est l'indépendance
du Québec
quel est votre choix
puis on a pas mal plus de chance d'y
arriver que de faire référendum sur les
indépendants
le privé en santé nous on propose plus
de privé mais du privé gratuit
ça va permettre d'innover et moi
j'aimerais ça poser une question
monsieur Nadaud Dubois là les dizaines
de milliers de personnes qui sont faites
opérer pendant pandémie ou privé
gratuitement qu'est-ce que vous leur
dites que tu as pas une bonne idée parce
que c'est pas votre
ideologie qu'est-ce que vous leur dites
à ces personnes-là qui ont été
satisfaite qui ont rien payé c'est le
goût vous le savez là que dans un
contexte d'urgence dans un contexte de
crise sanitaire sans précédent on était
d'accord d'avoir un recours temporaire
et limité ou privé sur le coup il y
avait des gens qui mourraient présents
mais est-ce que l'avenir de notre
système c'est de se rapprocher d'un
modèle privé ou est-ce que l'avenir de
notre système c'est de reconstruire
notre système public c'est là qu'on va
les violences de vision c'est pas
possible
vous êtes la seule sauf erreur là vous
promettez encore ce que d'autres chefs
en premier avant vous c'est à dire un
médecin de famille par québécois
vraiment est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut
croire à ça compte tenu de l'échec
continue depuis 20 ans je comprends les
sceptiques mais on n'a pas le droit de
laisser tomber plus d'un million de
Québécois on va se rendre à combien un
point 5 millions 2 millions de Québécois
qui ont pas accès à médecin de famille
pourquoi est-ce que ailleurs dans le
monde sont capables de le faire puis
nous au Québec on serait pas capable de
le faire il s'agit d'aller recruter
davantage de médecins d'aller recruter
davantage d'infirmières d'aller recruter
davantage de PAP mais aussi de revoir
l'organisation du travail ce soir là
j'aimerais vraiment m'adresser là à tous
les professionnels de la santé là qui
font du temps supplémentaire obligatoire
il faut changer les conditions de
travail puis faire en sorte qu'on
élimine ce temps supplémentaire
obligatoire je pense à toutes ces femmes
toutes ces merdes de famille qui sont
pas capables d'aller chercher leurs
enfants l'après-midi parce qu'elles se
disent ah bah finalement peut-être que
je vais être obligé de rester puis elle
rentre à la maison puis elles ont manqué
un événement important avec leur enfant
cet équilibre famille travaille ne
jamais être à la bonne place ne jamais
être une bonne mère ou ne jamais se
sentir que tu es pas une bonne mère que
c'est peut-être sent me sentais pas une
bonne employée ça ça doit arrêter c'est
pour ça qu'on doit mettre entre autres
faim autant supplémentaire obligatoire
mais c'est aussi pour ça qu'on doit
faire en sorte que on a des ratios de
patients par rapport au nombre de
professionnels qu'on a qui sont la
proposer depuis deux ans supplémentaire
obligatoire ça revient effectivement
beaucoup quand on se promène dans les
établissements c'est possible ou non le
tour de table rapide est-ce qu'on peut
arrêter ça monsieur
plus d'infirmières ça prend plus
d'infirmières ça prend trois ans former
des infirmières qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
on a mis des incitatifs pour en ramener
de la retraite on a mis des incitatives
pour les étudiants qui étudient en
sciences mais un moment donné il y a
personne ici peut faire de la magie mais
c'est pas vrai c'est qu'on a mis
l'argent dans des agences privées qui
ont pris les infirmières du public
qu'ils ont mis au public au privé ça
coûte une fortune un milliard au lieu de
200 millions c'est ça le plan de la CAQ
et les conditions de travail au public
pendant ce temps-là ce sont détériorés
donc faut fermer les agences mettre fin
à l'usage des AG privé et rehausser
substantiellement les conditions de
travail en même temps ce que la CAQ n'a
pas le courage de faire
le problème bien sûr c'est de qu'il faut
ramener nos infirmières puis toutes nos
soignants dans le système public mais
sous la gouverne de monsieur Legault
c'est pas juste qu'on en a pas ramené
c'est qu'ils ont continué à s'en aller
aux chutes Québec l'an passé c'est 478
démissions dans toute l'année cette
année en janvier puis juin c'est 526
démission enfin que le monde il continue
à s'en aller du système pourquoi parce
qu'on les traite pas bien et c'est ça
qu'il faut régler
le temps obligatoire
supplémentaire obligatoire c'est
évidemment il y a personne qui
souhaiterait ça il y a personne qui
voudrait vivre ces conditions-là c'est
vrai que les infirmières s'en vont mais
la solution c'est pas d'abolir les
agences privées par la suite ça va être
encore pire il va encore plus de pénurie
les filles ne veulent plus travailler
dans un avec pour un aussi mauvaise
employeur que le gouvernement du Québec
d'où l'importance d'avoir une
concurrence des employeurs tu vas
pouvoir offrir des conditions de travail
décentes à ces filles très bien on vous
entendu là-dessus sujet extrêmement
important aussi les soins à domicile là
il y a des différences fondamentales
entre vous il y a 48 000 personnes qui
attendent des soins à domicile
actuellement est-ce qu'on a les moyens
de les aider puis en même temps
payer 800 000 dollars par chambre
monsieur Legault dans des maisons
d'années magnifiques par ailleurs débat
que j'ouvre là-dessus mais est-ce que
les soins domicile il faudrait pas en
faire beaucoup plus qu'on peut pas tout
faire en même temps sur le bout en 2018
on avait promis d'ajouter 800 millions
en soins et services à domicile on a
ajouté deux milliards OK et on a le même
problème qu'on vient de discuter ça
prend des infirmières ça prend le temps
des former les infirmières maintenant
quand j'entends certains médecins en
opposition avec des maisons des années
ben voyons donc besoin des deux quand
une personne
qui sont plus autonomes puis ont besoin
d'aller dans une maison des années qu'on
doit ça à nos aînés on avait un texte ce
matin sur Radio-Canada qui montrait que
la rénovation des CHSLD à Montréal était
retardé parce que ça coûte trop cher
est-ce qu'il y a pas la réalité de
l'argent
de trouver travailleurs de la
construction rapidement
pour ça quand monsieur nado du bois dit
il va mettre 74 milliards dans le
transport collectif mais il va te faire
arrêter de bâtir les hôpitaux des écoles
on ne sait pas
la meilleure la meilleure maison pour
les aînés puis je mettrai ça tous les
aînés du Québec c'est la vôtre c'est
s'il y a un message s'il y a un message
qui a été entendu partout que j'ai
entendu partout dans toutes mes tournées
c'est ce message là c'est pour ça merci
merci à vous de le reconnaître puis
c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin d'avoir une
allocation aînée de 2000 dollars
parrainés non imposable qui arrive année
après année qui fait en sorte que c'est
pas un crédit d'impôt là c'est pas
quelque chose de de non réel c'est de
l'argent dans vos poches qui arrivent
année après année de la même manière
qu'au Québec collectivement on s'est dit
on a besoin d'avoir une allocation
famille qu'on est alors donc le
corollaire puis je vous pose la question
monsieur Lego dit on peut faire les deux
est-ce que vous laissez tomber les
maisons pourraîner ce programme là on
finit ce qu'on a à finir mais on doit
investir de manière important dans les
soins à domicile et donner les moyens
aux aînés de pouvoir dans certaines
maisons qui ont commencé on veut les
terminer mais en poursuit pas ça parce
qu'il faut s'investir dans les soins à
domicile
les aînés sont une richesse pour notre
société il va falloir commencer à le
dire piagir en conséquence et donc les
écouter ils veulent des soins à domicile
ils veulent vieillir à la maison et ça a
donné que c'est un modèle pas mal moins
coûteux que les maisons des aînés à un
million de dollars par chambre ce modèle
là qui est dépassé il n'est pas viable
financièrement et il isole des gens qui
voudraient rester plus longtemps
possible à la maison c'est pour ça que
nous on a on s'est engagé financièrement
à tripler l'offre de soins à domicile et
que on va se préoccuper également des
CHSLD parce que c'est facile couper un
ruban puis prendre des photos devant une
maison des années mais pendant ce
temps-là la qualité de la nourriture la
climatisation la qualité du bâtiment
dans les CHSLD soit on n'a pas fait
grand chose donc à un moment donné il
faut être transparent et cohérent dans
la dignité des années ça devrait pas
être négociable dans notre société moi
j'accepte pas que la génération qui a
construit le Québec en ce moment elle
est part de vieillir parce que la peur à
cause de ce qu'elle a vu dans les CHSLD
et la solution la plupart des gens sur
le plateau ici ce soir s'entendre c'est
un grand virage national vers les soins
à domicile pour finir les chantiers qui
ont été commencés mais la priorité
ensuite c'est quoi les soins à domicile
permettent aux aînés du Québec de
vieillir à la maison et aussi rénover
les CHSLD existant parce que c'est là
qu'il faut commencer les hommes et les
femmes qui vivent dans ces institutions
là vivent pas bien ils vivent pas dans
dignité puis moi j'accepte pas ça faut
investir dans nos CHSLD tout en prenant
le virage vers les soins à domicile
évidemment que des chambres à un million
de dollars on n'aura pas les moyens d'en
payer à tout le monde puis monsieur le
Gaulle c'est très bien je comprends que
c'est effectivement ça paraît bien
politiquement pour les chanceux de la
loterie des maisons des années mais
malheureusement c'est pas viable pour
l'ensemble de la population je pense
qu'on une espèce de consensus ici là
puis c'est vrai on connaît mais on le
vit quelques nos grands-parents les
aînés là les garder le plus longtemps
possible à la maison je pense que c'est
la meilleure chose la chose la plus
souhaitable autant pour les années que
pour les familles qui voulons les
visiter c'est pour ça qu'on veut oui on
va investir évidemment dans les soins à
domicile mais il y a aussi la question
des aidants naturels ou également où il
va falloir investir davantage parce que
eux aussi ont un rôle primordial à jouer
si on veut les maintenir nos aînés le
plus longtemps possible à la maison les
gens les gens ont vu voient les
différences de programmes on est là pour
ça la santé mentale je ne peux pas ne
pas vous parler de santé mentale il y
avait des demandes pour que des
psychologues du privé soient transférés
au public pendant la pandémie les
adolescents entre autres qui appelaient
le
CLSI qu'on disait un an un an et demi
d'attente bon on fait quoi là vous
faites quoi en matière de santé mentale
depuis là-dessus là je pense que c'est
important puis on voit on commence à
voir mesurer l'impact ce qui s'est passé
ces dernières années on a vu que ça la
santé mentale des Québécois était
durement affectée particulièrement les
plus jeunes on voit même une étude
maintenant de l'Université de Sherbrooke
qui nous apprend qu'elle a détresse
psychologique la dépression est rendu à
50% chez les jeunes
on fait quoi on propose on propose un
sommet dans les 100 premiers jours puis
d'ailleurs je tends la main aux autres
parties j'aimerais que ça se fait de nos
façons non partisanale parce que le
sujet trop important pour commencer à
faire de la politique avec ça faire un
sommet parce qu'on y arrive pas je
savais que les effectifs très bien il va
falloir
mais la santé mentale ça devrait pas
être un tabou premièrement ça devrait
pas non plus être luxe puis notre
système de santé publique devrait
traiter seul la santé mentale sur un
pied d'égalité avec la santé physique ça
ça veut dire investir massivement pour
rapatrier les psychologues qui ont
quitté le système public dans le système
public vous voulez ramener au plus au
public avec les salaires du pavé
bonifiant leur salaire en bonifiant leur
fonction en améliorant leur autonomie
professionnelle il faut que ce soit
aussi simple se faire traiter pour la
santé mentale que se faire traiter pour
un bras cassé dans notre système de
santé publique vous opinez d'accord avec
ce que Monsieur Nadaud Dubois vient de
dire et j'ajouterai que non seulement
faut rapatrier dans le système public
des psychologues disponible mais quand
je vous parle d'un CLSC renforcé c'est
toutes sortes de professionnels qui sont
là pour offrir en prévention un soin ou
une intervention avant que d'autres
choses de plus graves se produisent donc
il faut penser aussi à la prévention
parce que c'est moins coûteux c'est plus
intelligent mais surtout c'est plus
humain d'avoir des ressources en
prévention que de guérir leur temps
Madame anglais qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour
faire face à ces demandes de
consultation
en santé mentale vous allez d'abord
permettre de dire que c'est un sujet qui
me touche personnellement beaucoup parce
que je sais c'est quoi être une petite
fille de 10 ans puis de se lever le
matin puis de te dire que si tu fais pas
ton lunch puis le linge de ta petite
sœur il y en aura pas de lunch parce que
ta mère est pas capable de passer à
travers ces enjeux de santé mentale puis
ça c'est mon histoire personnelle mais
c'est l'histoire de milliers de
québécois il y a 10 ans pas il y a 20
ans maintenant aujourd'hui on ne peut
plus considérer la santé mentale comme
étant un sujet parmi tant d'autres on
doit avoir un accès universel pour des
soins de psychothérapie c'est ce qu'on
propose que vous alliez dans le privé
que vous alliez dans le public vous
pouvez utiliser votre carte de la RAMQ
pour obtenir des soins c'est ça dont on
a besoin aujourd'hui au Québec en 2022
psychologues qui sont au public pour
être compétitif avec le privé mais je
veux quand même répliquer à ce que
Monsieur dum dit tantôt à propos des
deux dernières années parce que Monsieur
dum durant deux ans il a joué le rôle
d'un agitateur là qui a profité de la
souffrance des gens au Québec ils
pensent que c'est pas vrai qu'il y a eu
moins de décès au Québec franchement là
c'est irresponsable goût la façon dont
agit monsieur
québécois
tout ce que vous toujours tomber
là-dedans là vous êtes pas capable
d'admettre qu'il y a un problème de
santé mentale vous êtes prêts
vous n'êtes pas capable d'admettre que
c'est les enfants du Québec sauf à cause
de vos discussions est-ce que vous êtes
au Québec non monsieur Lego
monsieur Lego on a plus de 1000
Canada on ne peut sacrifier deux fois
plus d'années monsieur
vous avez été responsable avec les
enfants du Québec monsieur Legault
n'oubliez jamais ça
très bien ça se met fin à ce thème de la
santé prochaine thème éducation et
service aux citoyens
valoriser l'éducation c'est l'avenir du
Québec c'est l'avenir de nos enfants il
y a beaucoup d'endroits défavorisants à
Montréal remettre en face sur
l'éducation ça pourrait aider beaucoup à
ces gens-là à sortir de certains
problèmes beaucoup de personnes de
difficultés à trouver des places en
garderie que c'est un enjeu assez
problématique très difficile d'avoir une
place en garderie là il y a des années
d'attente question
la clé ça va être les conditions des
éducatrices autant au milieu familiaux
quand c'était parce que pas d'éducatrice
pas de place les écoles publiques ça
m'arrache le cœur de voir dans quel état
beaucoup de ces écoles se trouvent
que beaucoup aussi manque de personnages
d'enseignants dans les écoles
vous êtes enseignants vous voyez des
gens partir oui il y a beaucoup de gens
qui partent c'est soufflant il y a des
questionnements à savoir est-ce que je
vais être capable de faire 20 ans dans
la profession ce serait quoi les moyens
concrets mis en place pour garder les
enseignants dans la profession
j'ai rencontré Noémie Dumas dans une
école de Rosemont je suis entré dans
l'école il y avait plein d'enseignants
physiciens qui ont une question pour les
chefs et les descendue en bas puis j'ai
été frappé elle m'a dit ça fait deux ans
que j'enseigne et je songe déjà
peut-être à quitter
parce que la charge de travail parce que
l'aide insuffisante la difficulté les
élèves dans les classes normales la
question puis vous avez 35 secondes pour
y répondre madame Anglade vous êtes la
première comment faire pour convaincre
les Noémie du mode de ce monde de rester
dans les salles de classe
mais j'entends le message de Noémie puis
j'ai rencontré Sarah il y a deux jours
puis Sarah me disait qu'après 4 ans elle
avait décidé de quitter la profession
d'enseignement parce qu'elle était plus
capable parce qu'elle vivait un autre
personnel était plus capable de faire
face à la musique parce que ils n'ont
pas suffisamment de ressources il y a
des classes qui sont bondées ici tu as 8
personnes qui souffrent par exemple d'un
TDAH ou qui ont besoin d'aide ils n'ont
pas les ressources nécessaires ce qu'il
faut c'est aller recruter pour trouver
des ressources pour soutenir nos
enseignants dans un premier temps puis
faire en sorte qu'on valorise
véritablement la profession j'ai été
élevé par deux profs l'éducation pour
moi c'est fondamentale Gabriel Nadaud
Dubois 35 secondes ça fait 10 ans que je
me bats pour l'éducation c'est une des
valeurs qui est extrêmement
importante pour moi puis on réglera pas
les problèmes de notre système
d'éducation si on n'arrête pas c'est
exode là dont vous venez de parler des
profs et de l'ensemble des
professionnels qui quittent ce que les
enseignants enseignants nous disent
qu'on les rencontre je rencontre pas mal
c'est qu'ils ont besoin de renforts ils
ont besoin de professionnels qui
viennent les aider parce qu'il y a
quelques années il y avait trois quatre
élèvent en difficulté dans une classe
maintenant il y en a 10 il y en a 15 les
enseignantes sont plus capables
d'enseigner faut leur ramener du renfort
c'est la priorité en éducation monsieur
Legault 35 secondes
ça a toujours été ma priorité ça sera
toujours ma priorité tout ce que j'ai
dans vie c'est à cause de l'éducation
dans quatre dernières années on a
augmenté le budget de l'éducation de
26%. on a augmenté salaire des
enseignants de
15%. il y avait pas beaucoup d'appui
chez mes amis le quand je disais je veux
des négociations différenciées avec les
syndicats donc il faut valoriser la
profession d'enseignants ça prend quatre
ans avant de former un enseignant on a
mis des bonnies pour ceux qui vont
étudier en éducation donc faut continuer
Eric duen 35 secondes mais c'est
évidemment que la première chose c'est
de valoriser les enseignants développer
le sentiment d'identité à l'école on a
parlé tout à l'heure de la santé c'est
un peu malheureusement le même problème
qu'on retrouve en éducation souvent ces
gens-là l'impression d'être des espèces
de pions dans un système ultra
centralisé ultra bureaucratisé avec
plein de monde au-dessus de leur tête
ils ont pas l'impression d'être un
humain qui a une marge de manœuvre que
le lien avec les parents il faut
décentraliser tout ça ça a un impact
direct sur le travail de l'enseignant au
quotidien ça lui permet d'avoir une
marge de manœuvre d'avoir ses propres
projets avec ses enfants et c'est ça
qu'il faut valoriser dans le Québec de
demain merci Paul Saint-Pierre plat
Mondon conclusion mais moi je suis très
heureux d'entendre que tout le monde
veut revaloriser le rôle du professeur
donc j'invite tout le monde à être
cohérent et travaillons avec les
professeurs à trouver les solutions
lorsqu'on écoute il nous disent nous on
est là pour la mission de l'enseignement
donnez-nous les ressources
d'accompagnement psychologue
orthopédagogue pour qu'on puisse
elle nous a touché petite suite avec
elle c'est très court
mais je pense pas que c'est une question
naissante salaire c'est aussi savoir
c'est quoi les outils qui pourraient
nous a donné pour aider concrètement les
élèves dans le besoin
parce qu'on a de la difficulté à avoir
du soutien en classe
je le répète là je fais deux ans qui
travaillent dans les écoles peut être
plus clair elle me disait je sais pas si
je vais arriver jusqu'à ma cinquième
année vous commencez le débat ouvert
monsieur Dumas quand on entend des
enseignants comme ça parce que c'est une
richesse on en a besoin des filles comme
elles en centaine vous savez que la
rentrée scolaire il manque encore des
profs le gouvernement a été obligé de
faire ça même les chauffeurs d'autobus
il y a macéine rentrée scolaire très
difficile pour plusieurs parents du
Québec moi je pense qu'il faut oui il
faut mettre des ressources oui ça prend
de l'aide oui il y a des il y a des
enfants qui ont besoin aussi d'un
cheminement particulier donc il faut
diversifier l'offre il faut impliquer le
parent également au cœur parce que
souvent on oublie le parent pareil comme
c'était juste la bureaucratie qui devait
décider pour nous c'est très important
parce que conservateur que le parent
soit au cœur des décisions monsieur Hugo
je vais vous donner un droit de parole
parce que comme c'est le premier
ministre vous parlez à vous dire oui
c'est bien beau les salaires mais j'ai
besoin d'aide j'ai besoin d'aide dans la
classe
parce que et je regarde depuis 4 ans
depuis qu'on est là on rajouter 2000
orthophonistes orthopédagogue et
professionnel pour les enfants qui ont
dû discuté l'apprentissage passer
d'abord de ses enfants là il y en a
25%, ces autres qui vont décrocher
éventuellement donc il faut continuer ça
prend 4 ans pour former des
orthophonistes des orthopédagogues on
est en train de le faire mais encore une
fois on peut pas faire de magie les 2000
qu'on pouvait embaucher on les embauchée
quand on va être capable d'en faire plus
on va en faire plus monsieur c'est
incroyable quand même parce que je viens
de parler de donner du renfort c'est
exactement ce que Noémie du maudit on a
besoin de renfort dans nos classes et
l'argent s'achète pas tout dans la vie
ces femmes là se sont en grande majorité
des femmes veulent des meilleurs
conditions de travail puis il y a un
seul parti politique ici sur cette scène
qui a prévu dans son cadre financier des
sommes réservées pour une bonification
générale des conditions de travail dans
l'ensemble des services publics y
compris en éducation
réduire l'analphabétisme et on a proposé
des mesures en fonction de cet
objectif-là c'est un sujet trop souvent
tabou et je pense que si on nomme on
aime notre langue française il faut se
donner cet objectif-là et les moyens qui
vont avec parce que du chemin à faire
effectivement ça des impacts à tous les
niveaux l'estime de soi l'économie mais
surtout c'est notre langue française je
veux donner un prix aux parents des
milliers de parents qui ont organisé une
chaîne de courriels j'étais inondé
depuis deux semaines vous aussi
j'imagine sur le problème des écoles à
trois vitesses mais déjà ce qu'on entend
et je pense que ça vaut la peine privé
des cheminements particuliers dans les
écoles publiques soit qu'on paye ou
qu'on paye pas mais les bons élèves vont
là et il reste les classes ordinaires
beaucoup d'élèves en difficulté ce qu'on
appelle le système à trois vitesses
qu'est-ce qu'on fait vous avez des
positions différentes là-dessus madame
anglais est-ce qu'on change
la première chose que j'aimerais faire
c'est m'adresser à tous les adoles tous
les ados qui écoutent qui nous écoutent
ce soir puis tous les parents des ados
moi je sais là que j'en ai un à la
maison qui a 15 ans puis c'est difficile
de le réveiller à 6h du matin à moins
que ce soit pour aller faire une
pratique de football la réalité là c'est
que aujourd'hui pour accrocher nos
jeunes il faut qu'elle ait aussi des
programmes de science études d'art
études de sport études puis nous ce
qu'on propose c'est que c'est programme
là dans notre école publique soit
gratuit et que ce soit ça dépendent pas
du portefeuille de tes parents pour que
tu puisses participer à ça il y en a
déjà des centaines de milliers qui
participent 200 000 élèves qui
participent à ça mais ça c'est un moyen
de raccrocher nos jeunes puis de faire
en sorte qu'il en profite et ça ça
contribue à faire en sorte que l'école
publique soit réellement publique bon
quelqu'un là dessus qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec ça monsieur ce que j'ai envie de
rappeler à tout le monde qui nous écoute
ce soir c'est que ce problème là de
l'inégalité des chances entre les
enfants du Québec c'est un le problème
qu'il faut le régler c'est vous qui a
60% des jeunes qui peuvent par une école
privée vont à l'université 60%. les
jeunes dans les classes publiques
régulières c'est 15%. ça veut dire là
que si vous ne laissez pas dans le bon
cas vous vous abolition les écoles
privées ou dans une ou dans bonne
famille vous avez moins de chance de
réussir votre vie puis moi j'accepte pas
ça faut que nos écoles publiques au
Québec donnent les mêmes chances à tout
le monde c'est une question d'égalité en
tous les petits gars toutes les petites
filles du Québec fais quoi avec ça on
garde c'est d'améliorer nos écoles
publiques puis on avait promis en 2018
d'ajouter une heure par jour ça c'est 5
heures par semaine dans toutes les
écoles secondaires pour faire trois
choses plus de sport plus d'activités
artistiques plus d'aide aux devoirs
savez-vous quoi on le fait donc ça
faisait des autobus jaunes là maintenant
une heure plus tard les jeunes qui sont
dans nos écoles publiques et en plus de
sport plus d'or plus de devoir faut
continuer dans cette direction ok mais
on garde les entre guillemets les trois
vitesses vous vous dites on rend gratuit
les programmes particuliers absolument
et Québec Solidaire a le Parti québécois
vous dites l'école privée
ultimement c'est terminé c'est à dire
qu'il faut rééquilibrer le financement
parce que là on accélère la part du
privé et c'est vraiment trop à vitesse
c'est la troisième vitesse créer des
environnements d'apprentissage où les
écoles sont vétustes monsieur Legault
c'est un fait 59% des environnements ou
il y a trop de cas nécessitant un
soutien spécifique dans la classe les
ratios sont trop grands donc il y a une
question d'équité pour le public
là-dedans ou est-ce qu'il faut
rééquilibrer à la faveur du réseau
public pour une chance égal pour tous
les enfants il faut également peut-être
ajouter quelque chose quand même parce
que moi ça va m'avait beaucoup marqué
quand mes enfants sont rentrés à l'école
les effets scolaires qu'ils soient
gratuits puis quand on va sur le service
de garde sur l'or du linge c'est pas
normal que les parents aient à payer 800
dollars juste pour avoir son enfant qui
est un lunch à chaque jour à l'école
publique ce n'est pas normal ça ça
devrait être assumé par l'État et ça
c'est ce qu'on propose également c'est
comme ça qu'on va rendre l'école
publique réellement
monsieur roi parce que ça c'est vrai que
c'est un vrai problème là même nos
écoles publiques primaires et
secondaires sont même plus gratuites il
y a de plus en plus de frais et monsieur
Legault a pas réglé ce problème là les
frais continuent de se multiplier dans
nos écoles publics publics
nous on va réduire cette facture là la
facture de la gratuité scolaire puis on
parle d'économie là qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à 600 dollars par année par
famille ça c'est une urgence nationale
au Québec que nos écoles publiques heure
devient rapidement faut pas acheter le
bébé avec l'eau du bain le les écoles
privées ont un bénéfice extraordinaire
sur la société québécoise d'abord et ça
coûte moins cher à l'ensemble des
contribuables pour le rappeler que les
écoles publiques pour chaque élève puis
l'autre à faire c'est que ça lui a
permis une concurrence on ne veut pas
reproduire avec l'éducation ce qu'on a
en santé qu'un monopole inefficace
centralisé bureaucratisé monsieur
Legault en 2018 au débat des chefs aviez
dit j'avais demandé à la toute fin
est-ce que vous mettez votre siège en
jeu sur un sujet vous avez dit
maternelle 4 ans vous en souvenez
évidemment vous en aviez promis 5000 il
y en a 1610 je crois est-ce qu'on
continue où on arrête là j'aimerais
d'abord
le nombre de classes de maternelles 4
ans il y a des parties ici qui sont cons
parce qu'ils défendent les CPE ils
voient ça comme en opposition nous on
offre le choix aux parents c'est quoi
l'avantage entre autres des maternelles
4 ans c'est que c'est des dans des
écoles primaires où il y a plus
d'orthophonistes pour les autres années
donc on veut continuer ça marche dans
beaucoup de pays mais là il y a des
parties ici là qui sont contre les
maternel 4 ans je comprends pas ça
juste que quand on gouverne il faut
prioriser et vous vous vous avez mis la
au plancher pour les maternelles
4 ans ça il est commissions scolaires
c'était vos grandes priorités pour les
familles et pendant ce temps-là la liste
d'attente dans les CPA augmentaient et
leur augmenter sous votre gouverne elle
a augmenté chaque place qui manque mais
potentiellement c'est une femme qui va
vous aider au travail ça ressemble à un
gros ça ressemble étrangement à la
maison des années ce qu'on ouvre
quelques maternelles 4 ans puis pendant
ce temps-là les garderies ferment puis
les parents puis les enfants par
dizaines de milliers on était rendus à
50 000 enfants sans place en garderie et
là monsieur lebout nous donne des
chiffres pourquoi vous sur ces
maternelles 4 ans
on est pour votre présence d'un pays
scandinave vous les connaissez bien
pourquoi vous êtes contre les
maternelles si je peux répondre s'il
vous plaît c'est pas une question de
mercenaire qui apprend c'est la question
de garantir à chaque parent et à chaque
enfant une place en garderie et vous
vous insistez sur vos maternelles 4 ans
et pendant ce temps-là tout le reste et
à l'abandon
de milliers d'enfants qui ont pas de
place nous on propose une place garantie
en CPF comme à l'école primaire c'est
aussi simple que ça monsieur Legault
sous votre gouverne il y a eu un recul
pour les femmes un recul important non
mais c'est pas une blague vous dites oh
c'est pas une blague
pour cent de parler
de merci merci un recul pour les femmes
pourquoi parce qu'on a des femmes mais
non mais c'est sérieux c'est sérieux il
y a des femmes aujourd'hui qui ne
peuvent pas retourner sur le marché du
travail parce qu'elles n'ont pas de
service de garde elles n'ont pas accès
elles veulent le faire mais ils sont pas
capables de le faire parce que toutes
les attentes ça les attentes elle a
augmenté ce qu'on doit faire au Québec
il y a eu une révolution quand on a fait
une petite révolution importante au
Québec quand on a fait les CPE c'était
sous avec Pauline Marois mais il faut il
faut le souligner aujourd'hui on doit
aller ailleurs il faut que les services
de garde soient rendus un droit ça veut
dire que quand on a un enfant et que on
travailler l'État est l'obligation de
fournir un service de garde de la même
manière qu'on a droit à l'éducation ça
nous viendrait pas à l'idée d'avoir un
enfant qui a 7 ans qui rentre à l'école
puis on lui dit oh non vous allez
attendre deux ans parce qu'on a pas de
place c'est la même logique qui devrait
s'appliquer pour les services de garde
et faire en sorte que ce soit un droit
ça c'est la proposition du parti
libérale avec 8 et 70 pour tout le monde
à travers tout le territoire peu importe
le service où vous allez c'est ça que
vous allez sur cette question là on
reste sur cette question est-ce qu'on
devrait ce qu'on doit réaliser oui
parce que je sais qu'elle aime ça sortir
cette phrase là mais on augmente les
salaires mais que les femmes on les a
pas traité équitablement c'est contraire
on a augmenté le salaire des enseignants
des éducatrices en fait c'est préposés
de 15%. puis les garderies là quand vous
avez quitté le pouvoir en 2018 il y en
avait autant
qu'aujourd'hui de place manquantes vous
aviez créé une histoire de maison de
fouilles il y avait 12 étapes à cause de
Tony Tomassi il y avait 12 étapes avant
d'ouvrir une place en garde de riz c'est
pas crédible on voit les femmes qui sont
sortis qui ont manifesté qui ont dit moi
j'ai rencontré des femmes qui ont dit il
y a des non monsieur Legault ça s'est
détérioré puis cet enjeu là il est
important parce que vous savez quoi en
terme d'emploi on veut avoir des
personnes qui soient épanouies puis qui
retournent sur le marché de l'emploi et
ça fait partie des solutions pour le
Québec monsieur rouelle en fait les deux
ont raison c'est que c'est à dire que
autant les libéraux que la CAC sous leur
leadership ils nous ont toujours promis
qu'effectivement il y aurait plus
d'attente pour les parents pour leurs
enfants CPE puis les deux ont donné un
bilan qui était totalement opposé ce
qu'ils avaient promis en campagne
électorale puis aujourd'hui l'ensemble
des partis politiques des autres partis
politiques proposent encore la même
affaire en disant on va régler le
problème des listes d'attentes mais il y
en a pas un qui leur règle pour nous la
solution c'est de donner un bon de garde
de 200$ par enfant par semaine aux
parents qui malheureusement n'ont pas
gagné à la loterie des CPE et qui sont
50 quelques milles à végéter sur des
listes d'attentes depuis beaucoup trop
longtemps et comme ça on va pouvoir
éliminer le programme des CPA avec cette
que vous envoyez ne risque-t-il pas de
tomber dans une oubliette mais c'est à
dire que les gens qui vont qui sont en
CPF qui sont satisfaits les parents vont
continuer à en CP on veut pas couper les
CP on veut pas enlever les CPE on veut
que les parents qui ont pas accès au CPE
puissent ou eux aussi avoir leurs
morceaux du gâteau aussi c'est des
contribuables aussi ils payent eux aussi
ont droit d'avoir une aide de l'État le
problème avec le plan de Monsieur dum
c'est qu'il veut donner 200 dollars par
enfant mais une place en CPE ça coûte à
peu près 250 donc c'est même pas raccord
sauf que ça veut dire il y a une
contribution du parent de 8 et 70 par
semaine par jour financé le modèle des
CPE ce serait un recul épouvantable
par an qu'il faut si ça donne exactement
le même montant que vous parlez le
reconstruire c'est un vecteur d'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes faut
croire dans ce modèle là Paul des
financer pour l'abandon je vous donne 15
secondes pour conclure là-dessus ce
qu'on se pose la question est-ce que mon
enfant va avoir le droit d'aller à
l'école primaire l'an prochain non on
finance une place pour chaque enfant qui
a besoin d'aller à l'école primaire nous
c'est ce qu'on propose pour les CPE tout
début de GT c'est tout simple très bien
prochain thème français immigration et
identité
[Musique]
on va embaucher du monde de l'extérieur
alors qu'il y a du monde ici qui
n'arrive pas à travailler ici en région
si on veut avoir des immigrants c'est
sûr que il faut leur donner la
possibilité de pouvoir se loger
les proches aussi qui sont limitation et
j'ai l'impression que les politiques
d'ici sont passées incitatives pour les
retenir au Québec
la loi 96 c'est pas en faveur de tout le
monde prenez des vagues me donner la
fierté d'être québécoise de parler
français alors que aujourd'hui il
parlait français c'est pas fort je crois
à la souveraineté du Québec
comment pensez-vous qu'on préfère une
meilleure job pour défendre le français
et en même temps il y a énormément
d'immigrations et comment on fait pour
inclure ces personnes-là et leur faire
sentir qu'une place ici parce c'est
juste ça qui veulent
alors je vous repose la question de
Madame médecino comment protéger la
langue française l'encourager mais en
même temps ouvrir les bras à
l'immigration première réponse 35
secondes chacun Gabriel ado Dubois je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec
avec cette jeune femme ce qu'il faut
c'est pas seulement faire un débat de
chiffres sur l'immigration c'est
construire un nouveau modèle
d'immigration qui fait les deux qui
ouvrent les bras où on accueille plus de
gens au Québec et où on met sur la
régionalisation sur la francisation en
milieu de travail et où on donne la
piqûre de la culture québécoise aux
nouveaux arrivants aux nouvelles
arrivantes c'est ça la meilleure manière
d'inclure d'intégrer de donner le goût
du français c'est de faire découvrir
notre belle culture nationale c'est ce
qu'on propose de Québec solidaire un
nouveau modèle qui va marcher pour le
Québec pour les gens merci
Eric duenne 35 secondes une immigration
réussie c'est essentiellement deux
choses pour le nouvel arrivant c'est
d'abord un emploi de qualité et c'est
aussi s'intégrer à la majorité
francophone pour nous ce sont toutes les
gares de chiffres sur les seuils le
chiffre à la limite c'est pas le chiffre
qui est le plus indicateur le meilleur
indicateur c'est est-ce qu'on peut oui
ou non intégrer ces gens-là sur le
marché de l'emploi et les intégrer à la
majorité francophone le rôle du
gouvernement c'est de s'assurer qu'ils
peuvent apprendre le français et qui
peuvent intégrer le marché de l'emploi
c'est tout simple que ça les guerres de
chiffres ça ne mènent absolument nulle
part ça ne fait que diviser les
Québécois merci Dominique Anglade ben
écoutez d'abord moi je suis d'immigrants
qui sont venus s'installer en 69 ici au
Québec et ma mère est devenue prof de
français mon père était prof également
et on est capable d'intégrer les
immigrants en régionalisant davantage en
donnant des cours pour la langue
française en les encourageant en
promouvant en faisant la promotion de la
langue française on est capable de le
faire mais on doit arrêter aussi de
pointer du doigt on doit arrêter de
diviser on doit arrêter de dire que
l'immigration c'est un problème ou c'est
une menace
progressivement au Québec là on a de
grandes choses à accomplir on est
capable de faire avec tout le monde
merci Paul Saint-Pierre plat molot je
pense qu'on doit discuter du modèle
d'immigration et juste pour que ce soit
clair lorsqu'on parle d'un modèle
d'immigration propre au Québec en
fonction de la spécificité linguistique
c'est pas du tout la même discussion que
les personnes parce que les personnes on
doit chercher à les accueillir les
intégrer leur donner toutes les
ressources pour que ce soit réussi
gagnant-gagnant pour tout le monde sur
la question du modèle faut pas non plus
tomber dans un tabou ou parler des
seuils tu deviendrais interdit parce que
c'est lié au déclin de la langue
française parce que le transfert
linguistique vers l'anglais des
allophones est trop importante donc
discutons-en de manière responsable pour
trouver le juste équilibre au niveau des
seuils merci monsieur Legault 35
secondes je te suis d'accord avec ce qui
vient des vrais débat c'est pas sur
l'immigration c'est sur notre capacité à
intégrer les nouveaux arrivants aux
Français et on a adopté le projet de loi
96 on a augmenté le pourcentage du
migrants qui parle français on a doublé
les cours de français pour les nouveaux
arrivants mais le premier devoir du
premier ministre du Québec c'est
d'assurer l'avenir du français puis pour
ça ben on a besoin effectivement de
limiter le nombre de nouveaux arrivants
qui parlent pas français merci monsieur
Legault débat ouvert qui commence est-ce
qu'il y a un danger justement je
reprends la balle au bon d'accueillir
trop d'immigrants Dominique Anglade vous
lancer donc ce débat ouvert et trop
c'est quoi à 70 80 90 comment vous voyez
ça
au Québec aujourd'hui en 2022 là on a
accueilli 70 000 nouveaux arrivants
aujourd'hui donc on est capable de le
faire quand monsieur Legault nous parle
de la capacité d'accueil je sais pas sur
quoi il a calcule mais elle est on est
capable de faire aujourd'hui et on sait
très bien qu'on doit franciser davantage
ce qu'on doit régionaliser cette
immigration et on peut le faire sans
diviser les Québécois monsieur Legault
parle de son projet de loi 96 parle de
son projet de loi 21 mais la réalité
c'est qu'il a divisé les Québécois sur
ces deux enjeux là on est capable de
s'unir là-dessus on est le seul parti le
seul parti ici à avoir voté contre le
projet de loi 96 et contre le projet de
loi 21 pour des questions de valeur
parce qu'il faut arrêter de penser que
on va protéger le français en enlevant
des droits on va le faire en faisant la
promotion et en faisant en encourageant
les gens à l'apprendre monsieur Legault
a dit par deux fois dans la dernière
semaine à 50 000 immigrants par année le
français décline
quelle est sa réponse à proposition au
québécoise de Québécois pour la suite
des choses continuons 50000 et c'est là
l'erreur 50000 c'est le chiffre qui a
été fixé par Jean Charret au nom de la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre à l'époque
évidemment qui n'a jamais été réglé et
ce que monsieur Legault veut faire à
type de partie chef d'un parti
fédéraliste c'est de maintenir ses
seuils là alors qu'il l'avoue très
ouvertement que à ce niveau là il y a un
déclin du français il y a un transfert
linguistique vers l'anglais nous on
demande que l'immigration économique
soit 100% francophone parce que ça
favorise l'intégration marché du travail
ça favorise la langue française et on
ramène à 35000 qui est le seuil des
années où le français progressait à
Montréal on veut également comme mes
collègues régionalisés on s'engage à 5
euros
c'est que quand le Parti québécois était
au pouvoir sur les immigrants choisis
par le gouvernement du Québec le
gouvernement du PQ acceptait qu'en est
seulement 50% vous avez fait au début de
votre mandat et toutes les premières
années de votre manteau on est rendu à
80% en cause la pandémie à cause de la
pandémie mais on va continuer dans cette
direction là en utilisant plus la
régionalisation les étudiants mais il y
a une différence de dire je suis un peu
d'accord avec vous que il faut pas aller
comme Gabriel nado Dubois et Madame
Anglade à 70000
moi je pense que 50 000 en régionalisant
en exigeant qui en un plus grand
pourcentage qui parle français je pense
qu'on peut y arriver moi je vous réponds
monsieur Legault c'est pas juste 50 000
c'est les 177000 immigrants temporaires
temporaire c'est le chemin Roxane et
votre planification mène au déclin le
plus marqué de l'histoire du Québec en
français et vous savez que votre loi 96
ne renverse pas ce déclin-là vous l'avez
dit deux fois que 50 000 celliers au
déclin du français et vous continuez
dans les mêmes politiques que Jean
Charest et Philippe Couillard et ça
c'est pas responsable pour la survie du
français en Amérique qui vont rouler
seulement 35000 immigrants qui est le
modèle pas possible 50 000 donc sûrement
pas possible de 70000 des libéraux puis
80000 de Québec solidaire moi ce que je
vous dis là c'est que si on exige qui
est nouveau qui est un plus grand
pourcentage qui parle français avant
d'arriver on va y arriver c'est ça le
pari qu'on fait très bien prenez
l'engagement que je vous suggère
temporaire mais ils sont temporaires
ce discours là sur la baisse des seuils
d'immigration il est déconnecté de ce
qui se passe dans les régions du Québec
moi j'ai fait le tour des régions
derrière la semaine tout le monde nous
dit on a besoin de renfort on a besoin
de monde si on francise bien si on
régionalise bien si on donne la piqûre
de la culture québécoise l'immigration
Québec ça peut fonctionner nous ce qu'on
dit là et c'est messieurs et Madame ont
des débats sur la capacité d'accueil du
Québec mais savez-vous que cette
capacité d'accueil là
de la régionalisation c'est beau sans
théorie ça fait des années qu'on entend
discours là mais malheureusement puis on
peut reprocher ça aux émigrants il y a
une attirance naturelle pour Montréal à
montré on peut pas nier cette réalité là
Monsieur Nadaud Dubois dit je me suis
promener en région j'ai écouté poser la
question sur la pénurie de logement dans
la plupart des régions du Québec si on
accueille 80000 personnes l'an prochain
est-ce que les logements vont par magie
être là donc on a une responsabilité
également d'équilibrer ça et 50000 si
vous êtes d'accord mais malheureusement
ce n'est pas un équilibre monsieur
Legault et vous le savez et vous avez
nié la crise du logement pendant 4 ans
et ça aussi ça des impact sur notre
capacité d'accueil oui il y a des
dizaines et des dizaines de milliers
d'immigrants d'immigrants temporaire sur
le territoire du Québec et la première
chose à faire c'est de créer une voie
rapide pour ces gens-là puis ces gens-là
monsieur Plamondon je vous rassure
d'accord ils sont déjà dans un
appartement ils ont déjà un logement on
n'a pas à choisir entre régler la prise
vous avez dit pour éviter que le Québec
devienne la Louisiane il faut rapatrier
tous les pouvoirs on en est où là dedans
est-ce que tout le monde s'entend qu'il
faut rapatrier tous les pouvoirs en
immigration d'abord c'est important de
se réplique le gouvernement du Québec en
1977 aurait patrié 60% la sélection des
immigrants donc on a déjà eu des gains
on a fait des gains sur d'autres sujets
avec le gouvernement fédéral mais c'est
certain si tous les partis se mettent
ensemble les Québécois appuient leur
rapatriement plus de pouvoir mais on va
voir plus de chance d'avoir un succès
d'abord le 60% là autant les libéraux
que le PQ quand tu étais là y acceptait
qu'il y en ait seulement 50% qui parle
français donc faut augmenter ce
pourcentage là on l'augmenter à 80% donc
commençons par ce qu'on contrôle
je vais vous entendre sur votre
opposition la loi 96 qu'est-ce que
là-dedans qui pour vous est totalement
inacceptable est-ce qu'il fallait pas
agir pour stopper ce déclin que le qu'on
a constaté dans les derniers chiffres il
faut agir pour le français puis faire en
sorte que dans le centre-ville de
Montréal on est des mesures claires
d'accompagnement de nos entreprises puis
de nos commerces ça il faut le faire
puis soutenir en fait les enfants dans
notre système d'éducation également dont
on parlait tout à l'heure mais ce qui ne
faut pas faire c'est enlever des droits
à la communauté anglophone il ne faut
pas faire c'est enlever des droits comme
ils l'ont fait pour lui pour les
immigrants également qui doivent
apprendre le français on est on n'a pas
besoin au Québec de se diviser on est
capable de se rassembler on est 8.6
millions on est 8.5
millions de Québécois on est capable de
se rassembler
interdire l'accès au Cégep en anglais
pour des francophones et des allophones
vous visez davantage les allophones mais
vous les vous les interdirez aussi pour
les francophones en quoi ça va aider la
langue française les démographes et les
experts nous disent que c'est une langue
de socialisation cégep qui influence la
langue du travail donc si on veut un
plan complet et on prend acte du déclin
rapide du français on va ramener les
seuils en proportion de notre capacité
d'accueil on va faire une vraie loi 96
avec des mesures structurantes comme la
loi 101 cégep une immigration 100%
économique mais également des mesures
pour que la loi 101 s'applique dans les
entreprises à Chartres fédérale on va
donc investir aussi en culture mais la
loi 96 c'est comme un remède placebo
essentiellement tous les experts sont
venus dire ça ne renverse pas le déclin
du français mais monsieur Legault nous
dit ben c'est quand même quelque chose
moi je pense qu'on est le seul parti à
dire on peut pas se contenter de quelque
chose sur le français mettons en place
une réformés qui de manière structurelle
nous garantit de donner un avenir aux
faits français en Amérique une
durabilité à notre plan de communes
est-ce que vous pourriez aller plus loin
dans un autre mandat le cégep ou aller
plus loin c'est pas ça la clé puis
d'ailleurs même monsieur Saint-Pierre à
Mondon en 2020 dans sa première course à
Chevry il était contre le fait d'étendre
la loi 101 au cégep la clé c'est
l'intégration aux Français des nouveaux
arrivants pour interdire comme veulent
faire monsieur saint-pierre-lamondon à
des francophones d'aller perfectionner
leur anglais dans un cégep anglophone
savez-vous pourquoi j'ai changé d'idées
parce qu'il y a des dizaines d'experts
que vous avez entendu comme moi
l'Assemblée nationale qui sont venus
dire que votre projet de loi
renverserait pas le français et ils nous
ont soumis des mesures comme celle-là et
moi je ne suis pas un climato-sceptique
de la langue puis je veux pas qu'on se
contente de demi-mesure décoratives
alors qu'on sait
accélérer jamais on ne veut en 4 ans un
déclin aussi important de la langue
française que sous votre ouvert monsieur
Legault et vous en avez la
responsabilité
très bien laïcité trois ans son passé
depuis l'adoption de la loi monsieur
Legouge pas je lance le débat avec vous
et c'est ouvert à tout le monde quels
ont été d'après vous les effets positifs
de cette loi l'interdiction des signes
religieux je pense ça apaise le peuple
québécois on a eu toutes sortes de
propositions on est allé avec une
proposition équilibrée qui va beaucoup
moins loin qu'en France où on dit les
personnes qui sont en autorité pourront
pas porter de signes religieux quand ils
font 400 en fonction ça veut dire que la
personne chez elle sur la rue peut
porter tous les signes religieux mais en
fonction ces personnes-là par respect
pour leurs clients pour leurs élèves
doivent être pas avoir de signes
religieux je pense que il faut pas
rouvrir le débat comme certains veulent
le faire ici mais c'était justement ma
question madame anglaise monsieur
Gabriel ado Dubois vous voulez rouvrir
le débat et replonger le Québec dans ce
débat déchirant j'entends le Premier
ministre j'entends nous dire ah ben oui
ça apaisé le peuple québécois c'est qui
le peuple québécois c'est quoi le temps
québécois aujourd'hui
tous ceux qui vivent au Québec il y a
bien des gens qui vivent au Québec qui
ne pensent pas que ça apaisé les choses
au contraire ça a créé des clivages on
sait que on sait que les on sait que
aujourd'hui au Québec on prend des
décisions à l'Assemblée nationale qui
n'ont rien à voir avec la religion rien
à voir on est un peuple laïque on le
sait mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on est
obligé encore une fois de diviser les
Québécois pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'est
pas capable de permettre à des
enseignants d'aller enseignants on vient
de parler en fait tout un débat sur
l'éducation d'enseigner peu importe ce
qu'il porte on a ça ne nous enlève rien
et ça permet à tout le monde ouvrez le
débat et vous vous abonnez
de permettre aux gens d'aller Dubois
c'est à peu près la même position chez
vous c'est à dire que le débat vous
dites qu'il est clos monsieur le goût
dit qu'il est clos moi ce que je vois
c'est que ce pourquoi il continue à
exister au Québec la loi elle est
contestée devant les tribunaux donc
malheureusement bon monsieur Legault le
débat il continue et c'est normal parce
que c'est une loi qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité au Québec il y a des gens
qui ont été blessés par cette loi puis
nous ce qu'on va faire c'est très simple
on va garder ce qu'il y a de bon dans la
loi 21 parce que la laïcité c'est
important de l'affirmer la séparation
entre l'Église et les toasts une valeur
démocratique importante mais on va
s'assurer que si une femme veut
travailler dans une école et puis se le
faire même si elle porte un foulard moi
je pense que ce qu'il faut c'est
appliquer une vraie laïcité aux
institutions et permettent aux individus
de vivre leur vie ça c'est une vision
solidaire de c'est quoi une vraie
laïcité qui marche pour tout le monde
qui rassemble respectivement
vous avez cédé aux radicaux de votre
partie parce que vous disiez exactement
le contraire la dernière fois si les
autres parties peuvent donner leur
position
québécois on constate que pendant plus
de 10 ans on a débattu de cette question
là il y a pas un argument qu'on a pas
entendu on a fait une loi un choix
démocratique une loi certes est
imparfaite aux jeux de presque tout le
monde au Québec mais c'est notre loi et
en ce moment le fédéral et des
municipalités canadiennes attaquent
l'invalidation de nos choix
démocratiques et c'est fort probable que
les tribunaux canadiens vont invalider
autant la loi sur la laïcité que la loi
101 et je reviens pas ce que le
fédéralisme de François Legault va faire
à ce moment-là mais il y a une notion on
a le droit de décider par nous-mêmes et
décider par soi-même c'est avoir un pays
c'est être indépendant au Parti
conservateur du Québec qui ont croit la
liberté religieuse évidemment cela étant
dit la liberté des uns arrête là où la
liberté des autres commence et je pense
que tout citoyen au Québec au droit
d'avoir des services publics de façon
neutre c'est pas compliqué le principe
c'est pas il y a rien c'est pas contre
une religion c'est pas contre un symbole
c'est strictement le fait qu'en tant que
citoyen on a droit quand on fait affaire
avec l'État d'avoir le accès à des
services totalement neutres est-ce que
le débat qu'on entend moins parce que
l'axe fédéralisme n'est plus et c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire ce qu'il était
est-ce que ce débat là monsieur Legault
est terminé d'après vous pour 10 15 20
ans il y aura toujours des gens qui sont
souverainistes et puis je pense que
c'est un projet qui est légitime mais ce
que je sens actuellement c'est que la
majorité des Québécois pour aux autres
c'est pas une priorité actuellement
court terme c'est l'inflation à moyen
terme c'est de relever le défi des
changements climatiques qui ont d'autres
priorités que faire un référendum sur la
souveraineté si elle va référendum
monsieur Legault vous voteriez oui on en
veut pas de référence
à diviserait des Québécois ce que je
conclue demain matin il y avait un
référendum pour répondre à votre
question à ma gauche ce serait oui ce
serait oui avec Québec solidaire ce
serait mes billes avec le Parti
conservateur puis peut-être avec avec
monsieur Legault avec nous ce serait non
le choix est clair on est imparti
fédéraliste et j'aimerais juste préciser
une journée quand on dit quand on dit
parti fédéralisme ça veut pas dire
s'écraser le rapport à Ottawa ça veut
dire être un partenaire un partenaire et
pas un adversaire nous on veut
travailler avec Ottawa et Monsieur Lego
vous me regardez en disant oui le
partenariat les meilleurs partenariats
c'est quand deux personnes se respectent
et c'est comme ça qu'on voit le
fédération fondamentale si on peut juste
monsieur le Gaulle la semaine dernière
en débat a dit au Parti libéral qui leur
ravit le titre du parti le plus contre
l'indépendance du Québec vous avez dit
ça et vous vous targuez d'être non
seulement fédéraliste mais vous vous
mentez d'être le plus fédéraliste votre
projet s'est détendre l'indépendance du
Québec le mien c'est de le relancer et
il y a des électeurs qui vous ont fait
confiance en 2018 parce qu'il voulait
remplacer les libéraux mais qui sont
indépendantistes moi je fais un appel à
ces gens-là puis je dis vous pouvez
maintenant voter suivant vos convictions
et ce que François Legault a essayé de
faire c'est d'éteindre un mouvement
légitime et surtout déterminer
le but là c'était justement d'arrêter ce
chicane le mousquet je suis fier c'est
que cette élection possiblement
potentiellement tourner la page sur 50
60 ans de chican au Québec on va unir
les Québécois on va parler d'une seule
voix on va être unis sur un paquet de
revendications par rapport à votre
avenir et on va arrêter de vouloir
commencer à ouvrir les chicanes
constitutionnels derrière nous s'il vous
plaît monsieur roi la question que les
gens doivent se poser à la maison ce
soir c'est ce que notre système
politique au Québec qui fonctionne bien
ce que notre démocratie est en santé
est-ce qu'on est en train de réussir
notre lutte contre les changements
climatiques puis la réponse à ces
questions-là c'est non les gens
participent de moins en moins à nos
élections les gens ont pas de pouvoir
les élections le Premier ministre
beaucoup trop de pouvoir au Québec peu
importe qui était si dans ce siège là ce
qui nous faut c'est un nouveau système
politique au Québec et pour nous c'est
ça le projet d'un nouveau Québec d'un
Québec pays c'est un Québec où on
repense notre système politique pour
répondre à une voix qu'on se rassemble
pour merci j'en profite pour dire vous
avez été exemplaire dans et le partage
du temps est pas mal équitable
une petite vitre pour vous
d'accord mais j'en ai quelques-unes
est-ce qu'on doit encore au Québec
prêter allégeance à la Couronne
britannique donc à Charles du roi
il y en a un qui est constant la
question Québec Solidaire a proposé un
projet de loi pour rendre ce serment des
légendes optionnelle madame anglaise
vous y étiez opposé est-ce qu'on doit
encore prêter serment à la reine tout le
monde le rapidement je pense que c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut revisiter mais
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que ça
désisterait de grandes discussions au
niveau constitutionnel etc donc c'est
pas une priorité c'est pas une priorité
c'est pas une priorité
ce qu'on cherche ou pas idéalement on
changerait ça mais c'est pas une
priorité on a d'autres choses pas mal
purge l'autre chatte mais c'est engagé à
le faire quand on a fait une motion il
l'a refusé et moi je vous dis je
prêterai pas sincèrement au nouveau roi
si monsieur Legault va être le sujet du
roi d'Angleterre c'est sa décision mais
moi je crois au Québec libre et
démocratique en 2022 là au Québec là
est-ce que quand on Éline aux députés là
on pense que ces gens-là devraient
s'agenouiller et pouvoir très serment au
roi d'Angleterre je veux dire une
affaire d'une autre époque on est rendu
en 2022 il semble qu'on pourrait penser
à autre chose les gens n'ont un système
de santé
inefficace on a l'inflation qui est en
train d'étrangler les familles puis eux
ils veulent partir un débat sur la
légende
et voilà l'animateur avait posé la
question
d'abord merci très bien je vais vous
faire entendre j'ai rencontré une
artiste peintre qui est en train de
créer une oeuvre c'est très court je
vous demande d'écouter on revient tout
de suite
c'est quoi le plan même pour la
prochaine année c'est par de pénurie de
main d'oeuvre mais les artistes nous on
est là
super comment encourager les jeunes
Québécois à consommer davantage de
culture du Québec tour de table
rapidement
très difficile ces deux dernières années
vous comprenez c'est peut-être
l'industrie qui a été la plus poquée
d'une certaine façon justement eu la
chance hier de dîner avec plusieurs
artistes et je sais que ces gens-là ce
qu'ils veulent d'abord et avant tout
c'est une reconnaissance de ce qui
viennent de vivre puis on y a un urgent
besoin qu'on les encourage
individuellement tous et toutes très
bien il faut donner la piqûre de la
culture québécoise à nos jeunes le plus
tôt possible dans leur vie nous on a
proposé de mettre en place quatre
particules
obligatoires dans toutes les écoles du
Québec parce que qu'on soit né à Parc
Extension à rouynoranda ou à Sherbrooke
on devrait tous et toutes qu'on est
jeune avoir le même accès à la culture
québécoise ici on leur donne la piqûre
assez tôt bah c'est jaune là vont
devenir des citoyens citoyennes qui
consomment plein de cultures québécoises
ça je pense que c'est un pas en avant ça
va aider le secteur culturel ça va aider
nos jeunes c'est une excellente
proposition on a un passeport culturel
qui ressemble mais la culture c'est
l'essentiel de l'avenir du français et
ça prend un bureau de promotion de du
contenu culturel québécois on veut
également doubler les budgets de
Télé-Québec avec un mandat de faire des
émissions québécoises soutenir tous les
budgets de création et en faire la
promotion ça prend également un crtq
c'est à dire que le Québec doit pouvoir
réglementer ce qui est sur nos ondes
parce qu'en ce moment c'est un
raz-de-marée chez les jeunes de très
bien anglais je le vis quotidiennement
avec les trois enfants à la maison mais
trois ados consommation de contenu qui
est en anglais sur les plateformes
numériques il faut absolument investir
davantage ces plateformes-là avec du
contenu francophone puis ça ça va nous
permettre non seulement de développer
l'aspect culturel et francophone ici au
Québec encore plus mais de rayonner à
l'international puis de penser que on
est dans le monde des centaines de
millions de personnes à parler français
et ça permettrait au Québec de se
positionner encore plus fort monsieur
LEGO en 2018 le budget de la culture au
Québec c'était 1,2 milliards par année
cette année c'est 1,7 milliards par
année on a augmenté le budget
49%. on a ajouté des sorties culturelles
j'essaie d'encourager la lecture sur mes
médias sociaux puis on a annoncé que ça
a été élus 65 millions de plus je vous
aimerez peut-être pas ça pour
Télé-Québec pour plus d'émissions
québécoise très heureux tant mieux tout
le monde se porte bien
rapidement là c'est un exercice que je
vais vous demander quel est votre plus
grand d'inquiétude pour les quatre
prochaines années tour de table inverse
très rapidement
l'économie verte là ça presse de réduire
nos GS puis créer de la richesse avoir
une vision pour la lutte au changement
climatique et régler la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre
les deux enjeux le plus structurant
c'est le français l'environnement et
pour ça ça prend transparence et de la
confiance vis-à-vis des gouvernements
Gabriel ado Dubois votre plus grande
agilité contre les changements
climatiques faut aider les familles à
sortir la tête de la crise de
l'inflation c'est les trois c'est les
deux priorités pour les quatre
prochaines années Eric Dream le pouvoir
d'achat des familles québécoises
d'inflation c'est ça qu'il faut c'est ça
le problème des familles québécois
préparation sans vous ça aurait pas
exister tout ça mesdames et messieurs
votre parenticipation en fin de semaine
on se voit le 3 octobre bonne soirée
bonsoir à tous bienvenue à cette édition
spéciale de 24 60 la près des bas
j'espère que vous avez passé une très
bonne soirée que vous avez été bien
éclairé par les chefs qui ont répondu ou
pas aux différentes questions qui ont eu
des échanges corsées ou pas certains
moments entre vous les avez entendu ils
vous ont présenté leurs idées les
échanges parfois engagés quelques
attaques il y a pas de cacophonie en
tout cas est-ce qu'il y a gagné ce qui
est un perdant qui s'est débarqué c'est
toujours un peu ce qu'on fait après un
débat et on va le faire au cours des 90
prochaines minutes pourquoi 90 minutes
parce que chaque chef va venir en point
de presse répondre aux questions des
journalistes pointent presque que nous
allons vous présenter en direct et mes
invités toujours Sébastien Bovet chef de
bureau Québec bonsoir Sébastien et
Guillaume bogot côté chef du bureau
politique de du magazine actualités
bonsoir Guillaume à Québec Valérie
Gaudreault qui est toujours avec nous
rédactrice en chef au soleil bonsoir
Valérie et puis Michel David qui va
joindre à nous une vingtaine deux
minutes alors je commence première
réaction générale rapidement impression
générale de ce débat
trois mots bravo bravo bravo moi j'ai
été séduit par la formule c'est à dire
que il y a pas eu de cacophonie ça a été
très pédagogique évidemment il y avait
pas beaucoup de débats de confrontation
entre les chefs mais ça leur donner
l'occasion de parler de leur programme
de confronter parfois les propositions
de leurs adversaires mais sans
cacophonie je trouve que ça a été un bel
exception ça devait bien se regarder de
la maison en fait parfois il faut avoir
l'impression que ça peut être des
entrevues séparés mais pour approfondir
pour relancer permettre la comparaison
entre les idées pour vous
comme d'hab et très instructif aussi ce
qui ce qui à mon sens devrait être bah
oui un peu moins peut-être c'était moins
chaud mais effectivement je pense que
chaque candidat pu placer ces éléments
de façon plus plus clairs
absolument je partage le constat une
très bon travail de patrice Roy aussi
il a mentionné même les gens étaient
exemplaires on pourrait dire de lui
aussi comme animateur beaucoup en fait
on était presque sceptique au départ
tout le monde disait on veut le temps de
s'exprimer en ça plutôt réussi en fait
et moins la recherche de la clip on aura
sans doute l'occasion au cours de 90
prochaines minutes d'en parler peut-être
moins de citations marquantes peut-être
moins ce désir de frapper des esprits
parce qu'on avait plus en fait ce soir
d'expliquer c'est à dire que avec tout
ce qu'on a dit avant à savoir sur quoi
devait visiter le tel chef le site de
l'un ou de l'autre pas de gagnant pas de
perdant c'est exéco c'est d'arriver j'ai
l'impression que Paul
saint-père-plamentaux encore ce soir a
eu un bon débat quelquefois il a dit
revenons au sujet où il s'est placé
au-dessus de la ministre je pense que il
marque des points puis il le sait quand
il fait ce genre d'intervention en
observait particulièrement Dominique
Anglade et le prix de soin de parler
souvent à la caméra donc d'essayer de
déterminer un contact avec le
téléspectateur elle a été moins effacée
que lors du premier débat François
Legault et Gabriel Nadeau Dubois ont été
correctes les attentes étaient élevées
pour Monsieur Nadaud Dubois puis
François Hugo pouvait pas faire payer
que au dernier débat
Eric dum je l'ai trouvé un peu plus
effacé ce soir dans les dans les
discussions
à certaines questions d'une certaine
façon mais je trouvais qu'il restait en
surface plusieurs fois sur son programme
tout à fait d'accord
je pense que plusieurs ont rempli leurs
objectifs je suis d'accord que Monsieur
LEGO a fait nettement mieux que la
semaine dernière pas beaucoup parlé par
contre de ce qu'il propose bien défendu
son bilan mais on a moins des fois un
petit peu oui un peu moins que la
semaine dernière mais effectivement
me semble avoir peut-être c'est
peut-être elle qui a eu le meilleur bon
par rapport à la semaine dernière et sa
façon effectivement de regarder la
caméra
ça semble-t-il l'authentique mais donc
de regarder la caméra dans les yeux on a
une dizaine de minutes devant nous avant
d'entendre les chiffres revenir sur leur
performance lors de ce débat chacun va
avoir 10 minutes pour le faire entre
chaque point de presse il y a deux
minutes donc on va rapidement Sébastien
vous avez l'honneur de commencer avec
votre choix de première extrait Valérie
avait très raison quand elle a dit tout
à l'heure qu'il y avait c'était plus
difficile de trouver des extraits dans
ce dans ce débat avec des confrontations
je pense qu'il y a deux deux trois mots
qu'on va dans ce qu'on va se souvenir
décoration d'Halloween et au Pays des
Merveilles c'est tout résumé dans cet
extrait
le gauche répond à votre
questionnaires 1994 la nouvelle économie
c'est l'économie verte nous notre vision
se développements économique c'est de
encourager les secteurs d'avenir et
accompagner dans cette
transitions
arrêtez de sortir les décorations dans
le Wing arrêtez de faire peur au monde
des merveilles
les deux se sont quand même ciblés tout
au long de la soirée donc il y a pas de
Texas et de Cuba ce soir
je l'ai mal être dû vous présenter ça
portait sur les changements à l'économie
québécoise qui serait provoquée par le
programme de Québec solidaire très bien
Guillaume si on peut entendre la clip si
c'est dans l'extrait où Monsieur le goût
vraiment questionné d'assez prime sur du
M par dans sa position par rapport à la
pandémie
monsieur dum durant deux ans il a joué
le rôle d'un agitateur là qui a profité
de la souffrance des gens au Québec ils
pensent que c'est pas vrai qu'il y a eu
moins de décès au Québec franchement là
c'est irresponsable le goût la façon
dont agit monsieur
tout ce que vous toujours tomber
là-dedans là vous n'êtes pas capable
d'admettre qu'il y a un problème de
santé mentale vous êtes prêts
vous n'êtes pas capable d'admettre que
c'est les enfants du Québec sauf à cause
de vos discussions est-ce que vous êtes
au Québec non monsieur Lego
monsieur Lego on a plus de ma pratique
sacrifier deux fois plus d'années
monsieur
qui responsable vous avez été
responsable avec les enfants du Québec
monsieur Legault
c'est l'extrait le plus corset
de la position des rids par rapport à la
pandémie qui on le présume aurait
peut-être fait plus de victimes en tout
cas la question se pose et il n'y répond
pas monsieur dumm en même temps à
l'inverse monsieur dum mais aussi le
doigt sur un enjeu qui est populaire
auprès de ses partisans cette idée qu'il
y a eu aussi des gens sacrifiés par la
pandémie que les enfants payent le prix
et d'autres également les sujets le
sujet c'était la santé mentale
délétères ou des faces à la pandémie
mais qu'est-ce que ça aurait été si il y
avait pas une mesure sanitaire voilà
mais c'est sûr qu'il y a eu un lien
entre covid et santé mentales mais là
monsieur Legault il allait sur le
sacrifice des aînés combien on aurait
perdu de plus d'aînés dans les sièges
et il voulait en parler et il a trouvé
l'occasion de le faire à ce moment mais
qui a gagné l'échange
je note le vocabulaire monsieur
l'histoire de tirer dans chaloupe la
semaine dernière monsieur Legault
monsieur Dumas avait employé le groupe
pardon avait employé le terme
irresponsable auprès des ridsm donc il y
avait peut-être une récurrence de ces
termes-là on se taxes mutuellement
d'être responsable dans ce dossier alors
vous avez choisi un thème qui qui vous
colle parce qu'à la peau à Québec à tout
le monde le transport alors vous avez
choisi un échange sur les fameuses
études pourquoi vous avez choisi cet
extrait je la trouve plutôt habile parce
que Monsieur dum il dit bon vous allez
voir l'extrait vous avez dit que les
études sont périmées hors pour le
tramway elle était vous dites que c'est
ok c'est vrai mais c'était aussi des
études du réseau de transport de la
Capitale c'est une étude au niveau
municipal c'est la ville donc ça paraît
bien peut-être de mélanger un le type
d'études et le contexte mais ça fait
quand même son effet du côté de Monsieur
alors on l'écoute
les études que vous avez que vous cachez
au Québec vous voulez pas les montrer
parce qu'ils sont périmés parce que
c'était avant la crise Center vous avez
dit ça on a entendu ça les études qui
ont été faites le tramway elles sont
aussi périmées parce qu'il y a 30 % de
moins d'usagers des autobus à Québec
présentement est-ce que vous allez
remettre le projet de tramway sur la
glace en attendant le renouvellement de
nouvelles études ou si ça c'est pas
pareil parce que le tramway vous êtes
pauvre alors que le troisième bien vous
voulez faire l'anglais la population
important la mise à jour post pandémie
évidemment on dit souvent que les enjeux
de transport à Québec dépassent
largement des frontières parce que si
tramway c'est quand même plus Québec
Québec on le disant en analyse de près
des bas on veut parler aux gens de
Québec et là les deux ont peut-être
marqué en tout cas leur position par
rapport à ce dossier là c'est
incontournable ce sujet-là même si
certains peuvent avoir l'impression
qu'on en a assez parlé oui
on passe à autre chose et bah par contre
un thème important pour Madame anglaise
elle est revenue depuis la campagne
toujours là-dessus accusé monsieur
Legault de pas parler de du cœur même du
problème en économie c'est la
c'est elle qui a abordé le sujet ce soir
que j'aimerais présenter je veux un peu
le punch parce que elle a voulu se
différencier des quatre hommes qui
étaient avec elle sur le plateau de
cette façon là mais aussi en parlant de
pénurie de main d'oeuvre c'est un sujet
qui qui est le Martel comme vous le dit
si bien depuis le début de la campagne
et il fallait qu'elle le c'est quand je
vous dis que Madame anglaise a mieux
performer cette fois-ci moins effacé
voici un exemple
vous écoutez tous ces messieurs discuter
et à la fin de la journée là aujourd'hui
un éléphant dans la pièce d'un point de
vue économique puis le défendre dans la
pièce s'appelle la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre il s'appelle le fait que on a
pas suffisamment de personnes puis au
début c'était un enjeu qui était
économique mais il est devenu social
parce qu'on n'a pas de monde dans nos
écoles parce qu'on n'a pas de monde un
service de la santé puis monsieur
Legault vous disiez en 2018 on va en
prendre moins c’était votre slogan on va
en prendre moins puis on va prendre soin
puis la réalité c'est que dans les
quatre dernières années on a pris moins
de pharmaciens moins d'infirmières moins
de préposés au bénéficiaires et le
résultat c'est que on a moins de soins
et moins de service
c'est intéressant parce que Madame
Anglade dans le premier débat c'est
comme si elle parlait on l'entendait on
l'écoutait on l'entendait mais on
l'écoutait pas c'est-à-dire que on
repartait tout droit ça passait tout
droit exactement ici
est-ce la vraie Dominique elle avait
l'air plus convaincu plus convaincante
aussi plus passionné dans sa défense
dans les solutions qu'elle veut apporter
aux problèmes de pénurie main d'oeuvre
donc c'est un exemple de la
transformation un peu qu'elle a opéré
ces derniers ces dernières années
avez-vous un autre extrait je l'ai dit
par rapport Dominique Anglade d'abord je
l'ai trouvé beaucoup plus ancré
effectivement par dans sa performance
elle-même et aussi par rapport aux par
rapport peut-être au programme ou
propositions libérales puis on sentait
qu'elle parlait avec un plus
convaincante et peut-être plus convaincu
elle-même dans ce cas pas son énergie vu
les pronostics en tout cas un bon moral
est-ce que je la vallée pour un autre
extrait où vous
dans le fond
elle a pensé aux travailleuses la santé
les infirmières notamment vous avez
choisi
l'extrait où elle parle du fameux temps
supplémentaire obligatoire qui est
toujours en vigueur on écoute cette
extrait en delà de temps supplémentaire
comme vous l'avez choisi d'ailleurs
l'extrait ce soir là j'aimerais vraiment
m'adresser là à tous les professionnels
de la santé là qui font du temps
supplémentaire obligatoire il faut
changer les conditions de travail puis
faire en sorte qu'on élimine ce temps
supplémentaire obligatoire je pense à
toutes ces femmes toutes ces merdes de
famille qui sont pas capables d'aller
chercher leurs enfants l'après-midi
parce qu'elle se disent ah bah
finalement peut-être que je vais être
obligé de rester ça ça doit arrêter
oui Valérie c'est quand même important
ça touche tellement de monde très
important dans la dans le dans la
manière dans le propos évidemment relié
à toutes les packs de cet instrumental
s'adresse particulièrement à main
féminine on a travaillé à la
conciliation travail famille toute la
réalité même de pénurie de main d'oeuvre
parce qu'on dit épuisé ces fameux ne
travaillent plus donc c'était quand même
très habile je pense qu'elle a bien
résumé et la forme dans ce sens là je
suis dans la continuité la des
commentaires de Sébastien Guillaume ça
vient parfaitement mon avis illustré à 3
ou 4 reprises j'ai noté qu'il y a eu cet
épisode sur le temps supplémentaire
obligatoire sur les gens qui avaient pas
de médecin de famille sur Adja m'adresse
aux adolescents aux parents
d'adolescentes dans le segment sur la
santé mentale ou l'éducation si je
n'abuse alors il y a eu vraiment cette
récurrence dans la manière de s'adresser
directement à la caméra donc je reviens
à cette idée de la nouvelle Dominique à
mon avis c'est elle qui a vraiment le
plus modifié améliorer sa performance
entre les deux ce soir donc elle se
démarque ce soir à l'issue se débat et
Guillaume notre extrait oui si on peut
avoir l'extrait du M infirmière
lorsqu'il parle des filles là aussi je
vends le punch mais ça lui est arrivé à
deux reprises ce soir
les infirmières s'en vont mais la
solution c'est pas d'abolir les agences
privées par la suite ça va être encore
pire il va encore plus de pénurie les
filles ne veulent plus travailler dans
un avec pour un aussi mauvaise employeur
que le gouvernement du Québec d'où
l'importance d'avoir une concurrence des
employeurs qui va pouvoir offrir des
conditions de travail décentes à ces
filles
sur la forme le fait de parler des
filles puis le fait aussi en parlant des
professeurs plus tard c'était peut-être
pas le meilleur choix de nous là pour
pour parler de ces
tours
mais je trouvais aussi que dans la
présentation dans cet extrait puis dans
d'autres extraits également je me suis
déjà quand même réussi peut-être à
monter le contraste que quand il y
aimerait son programme parce qu'il a une
vision quand même passablement
différente des autres mais sans aller
nécessairement très loin dans les
explications j'ai trouvé que souvent
effectivement resté en surface et aussi
dans les grandes lignes des
centralisations puis des grands
principes difficilement applicables avec
les explications qu'on a vu l'impression
que le public était prêt à recevoir
cette approche pédagogique des
programmes nous ça nous a pas appris
beaucoup de choses nouvelles parce qu'on
les connaît les programmes pour le
public j'espère
parce qu'on est sorti du
madame
anglaise adversaires qui vous ont laissé
cette place là puis monsieur le goût dit
que vous voulez mettre en lumière qu'il
traite inéquitablement les femmes c'est
quoi la relation que vous reprochez à
François Legault et sa façon de traiter
les femmes la première chose que
j'aimerais vous dire par rapport à votre
question c'est que je pense que j'ai
pris ma place ce soir parce que j'ai
imposé un certain nombre de thèmes qui
m'était cher qui qui vraiment témoignait
de ce qu'on veut faire au Parti libéral
du Québec première chose deuxième chose
c'est qu'il y a des enjeux fondamentaux
au Québec qui ont frappé les femmes
davantage la covid a frappé les femmes
davantage on a beau le tourner dans tous
les sens mais les services de c'est un
être recul pour les femmes il veut pas
le reconnaître il veut pas le dire mais
c'est la vérité alors quand on est
capable de reconnaître un problème on
est capable de travailler par rapport à
ça c'est parce qu'il fait je pense que
c'est important de soulever ça parce que
les femmes c'est 50 % de la population
au Québec est-ce que vous avez
l'impression fondamentalement que
François Legault traite inéquitablement
les femmes actuellement au Québec ici je
pense qu'il sous-estime les enjeux qui
sont reliés aux enjeux aux enjeux des
femmes on le voit avec les on le voit
avec les CPE puis lorsqu'on parle des
enjeux des femmes par exemple on a parlé
des des professeurs c'est comme si des
professeurs puis des enseignants c'est
comme si
la seule solution c'est l'augmentation
de salaire c'est pas juste ça c'est
l'impact de de la charge de travail la
charge mentale ce que les femmes vivent
au quotidien ne pas sentir que tu es à
ta place au travail ne pas sentir que à
ta place à la maison ça les femmes le
vivent partout tout le temps au Québec
alors c'est c'est de reconnaître que ça
existe et je pense pas qu'il est
vraiment la possibilité là ça fait
partie de ce que j'apporte aussi en
politique
est-ce que son gouvernement traite mal
les femmes
le gouvernement de François Legault ne
prend pas la pleine mesure des impacts
des décisions sur les femmes
l'exemple des services de garde sans
état quand on parle des enseignants sans
état quand on parle de nos infirmières
qui sont obligés de faire du temps
supplémentaire obligatoire sans être un
autre alors il faut réfléchir en
fonction de ça également si vous êtes
que vous avez pris votre place vous vous
donnez une bonne note je vais vous
laisser l'évaluer mais cela ferait vous
êtes bon dans les notes non cette
question là sentez-vous que vous avez
bien performer j'ai donné le meilleur de
moi-même
merci
bonjour madame Anglade Mylène crade de
la presse j'aimerais justement savoir
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de cet
échange justement sur la place des
femmes sur les garderies avec Monsieur
legon il vous a interrompu l'animateur
du rappel à l'ordre oui et puis il m'a
même dit encore ce que la formule est
seul j'ai oublié exactement mais comment
encore ce thème ce thème il est
important ce thème de la place des
femmes dans notre société il est
important puis si on veut construire un
Québec où on se rassemble on se divise
pas il faut prendre en considération
aussi ce que vivent les femmes au Québec
c'est c'était ça mon message puis il
faut savoir nommer les choses je l'ai
nommé mais qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé
de l'échange avec monsieur Legault de la
façon dont vous a répondu
toujours de manière paternaliste
d'approcher les choses toujours une
manière de dire des choses
alors que ce qu'on veut là c'est qu'il y
a une véritable compréhension de ce qui
se passe monsieur Legault un style de
leadership où il aime imposer sa manière
de penser moi j'ai un style de
leadership qui veut rassembler qui
écoute qui entend ce qui se passe sur le
terrain puisqu'il est capable de
traduire ça dans des propositions qui
sont concrètes que j'ai présentées
d'ailleurs ce soir c'est pas ce style de
leadership que François Legault a c'est
le mien et c'est ce que j'amène en
politique merci merci
bonjour Marc-André Gagnon du journal
madame Anglade on vous a vu dans les
derniers jours avec des gants de boxe à
un moment donné où était vos gants de
boxe ce soir
j'ai toujours des gants de boxe j'ai
toujours voulu dire quoi quand vous les
dites j'ai donné le meilleur de moi-même
mais en même temps est-ce que vous
auriez été ce que vous auriez pu être
plus à l'attaque un peu plus combatif
non ah ben je pense que j'ai été très
compatible je pense que dans les propos
je suis intervenu quand il fallait
j'étais parler des enjeux de pénurie de
main d'oeuvre j'ai soulevé des enjeux
qui sont très humains que vivent que
vivent les Québécois dans les propos que
j'ai tenu j'ai parlé beaucoup avec mon
coeur aussi de ce que les gens vivent de
ce que j'entends sur le terrain puis de
ce que j'observe moi comme mère de
famille comme comme citoyen du Québec
non je pense que j'ai été j'ai dit ce
que j'avais à dire parce que depuis le
début de votre campagne on a vu cette
tuile après tuile à quel point ce soir
c'est un moment important décisif pour
la suite des choses dans votre campagne
c'est un moment important mais ce que je
peux vous dire par contre c'est que je
vais continuer à travailler sans relâche
jusqu'au 3 octobre les gens qui me
connaissent le savent je manque pas
d'énergie je manque pas de
d'éléments pour c'est vraiment pousser
la machine jusqu'au fond et je vais
continuer de le faire
bonjour madame Anglade pour le soleil
François Legault attaqué beaucoup
Gabriel Lanaud Dubois durant ce débat
est-ce que vous êtes senti ignoré par le
Premier ministre moi je regarde les
temps de parole puis je pense que j'ai
eu des temps de parole je pense que je
suis dans le milieu là dans les temps de
parole qui ont été faits alors je pense
que sur l'économie on a eu de très bons
échanges qui montrent bien et qui
contraste la vision de François Legault
avec notre vision qu'on va amener d'un
point de vue d'un point de vue
économique et ça déconnexion par rapport
à plusieurs anges vous pensez pas que le
premier ministre ne vous voit pas comme
une menace
c'est pas à lui de choisir ses
adversaires c'est au Québécois c'est au
Québécois de choisir il a déjà fait
quand il nous a dit de pour qui voter
aux fédéral c'est pas à lui de décider
merci
je posais la question différente est-ce
que ce débat là a pu faire un peu servir
à redresser votre campagne il peut
surtout servir à informer tous les
Québécois sur les propositions qu'on
veut amener j'ai eu l'opportunité d'en
présenter plusieurs sur différents
thèmes puis moi j'ai aimé l'exercice
j'ai mis l'exercice de dire ben voici ce
qu'on amène voici ce qu'on propose et
voilà comment ça se différencie des
autres alors contente très contente du
résultat et vous pensez donc ça peut
permettre de convaincre des Québécois de
la pertinence ou de faire des gains ce
soir parce que
je pense que les Québécois qui regardent
ça aujourd'hui ils disent ah ben
peut-être que je savais pas telle
affaire ça c'est intéressant cette
manière de faire cette manière aussi
d'être d'avoir un leadership plus
collaboratif ce qu'on n'a pas avec la
CAQ aujourd'hui partout partout dans
toutes les décisions qu'il prend
François Legault imposent sa manière de
faire collabore pas avec les villes et
leur dit quoi faire collabore pas avec
le fédéral il fait il leur dit quoi
faire ne collaborent pas j'ai un
leadership qui est collaboratif qui fait
que tout le monde peut s'asseoir à la
table et qui fait aussi que tout le
monde se sent représenter qu'on arrête
de diviser les Québécois comme il le
fait notamment sur les enjeux
d'immigration mais de manière générale
comment ils divisent les Québécois merci
2 minutes 30 on va passer en anglais
malheureusement c'est tout ce qu'on
avait en français
qui ma pneus
de vous adversaires
dit que c'était un peu une manœuvre
désespérée de le soulever et
est-ce que vous pensez que votre
position sur le fait de réalisme est
devenu pertinente à nouveau réponse mais
oui c'est pertinent vous l'aurez noté
deux parties vont voter oui un des
parties on le sait pas c'est irréduum
c'est pas clair ce qu'il va faire
l'autre c'est François Lego il n'a pas
répondu à la question nous sommes les
seuls le seul parti qui dit nous sommes
très clairs et les questions du
fédéralisme elles étaient très claire
également le goût monsieur Legault me
regardait ah oui le fait d'arrivisme et
moi je disais nous forgeons des
partenariats et les meilleurs que j'ai
vu dans ma vie c'est où deux personnes
se respectent et ils travaillent
ensemble même dans la main pour régler
les problèmes voilà ma vision de
fédéralisme il n'a pas de vision de il
veut juste affronter et comme il
affronte les mains par exemple il n'a
pas de vision nous on en a une et on est
le seul parti fédéraliste question il y
avait des questions de vous qui
affrontez monsieur Legault sur les
façons que les femmes ont été affectées
depuis quelques temps il était question
de
s'infirmières Monsieur duem les a
qualifiés de filles quand pensez-vous
réponse je l'ai entendu aussi
je pense que ce n'est pas uniquement des
femmes dans ce domaine avant tout et
ensuite moi j'utiliserai le mot femme en
général
comment pensez-vous que vous avez été
une bonne combattante ce soir réponse
j'ai été vraiment très engagé dans le
combat et je pense que dans le genre de
leadership que les gens veulent voir
leadership moderne voilà ce que j'ai
affiché c'est partager son opinion le
dire quand on n'est pas d'accord et
emmener des idées contribuer j'étais
très très bonne à cet égard je pense
ça complète merci à tous merci beaucoup
alors premier point de presse de Madame
anglais après le débat les autres chefs
viennent dans quelques minutes dans deux
minutes est-ce qu'elle a donné le
meilleur d'elle-même
son intervention tourne autour du style
de l'édition c'est une question des
déchets pour elle oui elle a eu
l'occasion de se faire valoir ce soir
plus que lors du premier débat on
s'entend même si le bien performé ce
soir c'est rien pour la projeter comme
première ministre le soir du 3 octobre
mais ça lui permet de consolider sa base
d'essayer de sauver certaines
circonscriptions que de parties libérale
dont la sienne peut-être donc il fallait
qu'elle ait ce genre de performance il y
a une semaine il fallait qu'elle ait une
bonne performance elle l'a pas eu cette
semaine aujourd'hui il fallait qu'elle
ait de bonnes performance et quand même
dans les circonstances U et miser sur la
choisir le mot la clientèle des femmes
c'est intéressant mon sens elle le fait
dans le débat elle vient de le refaire
dans ce point de presse en soulignant
c'est quelque chose qui a souvent été
reproché à François Legault au fil de
son mandat
notamment que la pandémie a eu beaucoup
d'impact pour pour les femmes en
particulier c'est ce que Madame Anglade
met de l'avant et elle a trouvé il me
semble à travers le débat plusieurs mois
plusieurs façons en fait de passer ce
même message je vois qu'elle vient de
Valérie se défendait en disant qu'il
avait bien traité les femmes parce qu'il
avait aussi les salaires notamment
des enseignants et des enseignants aussi
mais surtout les enseignants qui étaient
majoritaires les infirmières et les
autres emploi santé oui et c'est le
temps en partie parce que justement
c'est un extrait que j'avais sorti
l'extrait un peu dans lequel il faisait
référence lors du point de presse c'est
un moment donné c'est le goût d'hier je
sais qu'elle aime ça sortir ça cette
phrase là quelle phrase
on cherche là continuez Valérie en fait
essentiellement c'était ça c'était
l'idée c'est comme si c'était une Libye
de Madame Anglade de dire à elle aime se
répéter ça le concrètement les femmes
donc il y avait quelque chose d'un peu
paternaliste ce qu'on reproche parfois
monsieur Legault alors il a un peu
refait tout en voulant dire non on aide
on protège les femmes on n'est pas de
mesure qui traite moins bien les femmes
et sur le taux sur lequel le dieu un peu
annuler les faits finalement de ce qu'il
souhaitait dire c'est à dire que les
femmes sont traitées équitablement et
devenir ces exemples d'emploi majorité
féminine
les adversaires de Monsieur Legault ont
soutenu madame anglaise
d'accord ça n'aura peut-être
très heureux d'avoir des battu ce soir
de l'avenir du Québec je voulais parler
de crise climatique je voulais parler de
crise du logement je voulais te positif
aussi parler du projet de société qu'on
a Québec solidaire je pense que j'ai
atteint ces objectifs là pendant ce
temps-là ce que je constate c'est que
François Legault continue à crit le plan
environnemental de Québec solidaire sans
rien proposer de concret sans proposer
aucun projet positif pour que le Québec
soit plus efficace dans sa lutte au
changement climatique donc
malheureusement monsieur Legault a raté
l'occasion de présenter son projet au
québecoise moi je pense que c'est ce que
j'ai fait ce soir
je vous monsieur caramel devoir vous
l'avez dit Monsieur Lego vous a attaqué
frontalement des premières minutes du
débat sur votre plan vert il dit que
vous vous êtes Gabriel au pays des
merveilles essentiellement
comment vous expliquer cette stratégie
là du premier ministre est-ce que vous
vous sentez même pas un peu utiliser
c'est à lui à justifier ces stratégies
moi je constate que François Legault est
pas à la hauteur de la situation en ce
moment là la crise climatique elle
appelle des leaders qui sont capables de
rassembler les gens puis de proposer des
solutions donner des choix écologiques
aux gens François Legault est passé
journée à critiquer le parti que le
meilleur plan d'environnement et lui il
propose rien chez le goût vit dans une
autre époque il a une vision d'une autre
époque et sa paru ce soir
en fin de départ sur le goût vous a
aussi reproché d'avoir cédé aux radicaux
je décide de votre partie sur la loi 21
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez puis
comment vous justifiez que vous ayez
quand même changé votre position sur la
loi 21e année maintenant qu'on a la même
position à Québec solidaire monsieur
Legault cherche toutes sortes de
manières de nous attaquer parce que lui
son projet pour le Québec c'est un
projet d'une autre époque il est pas
capable d'enthousiasmer les Québécois
québécoises derrière son projet donc ce
qui fait si nous attaquer mais vous avez
posséder
la position de Québec soldat et la même
depuis des années maintenant
du Journal de Québec lorsque vous sortez
d'un exercice comme celui-là vous dites
est-ce que vous trouvez que vous avez
mieux réussi votre coup ce soir que la
semaine dernière je pense qu'on va
parler les deux débats je pense que dans
les deux cas j'ai atteint les objectifs
que je m'étais donné ce soir j'avais
envie oui d'être combatif mais surtout
d'être positif puis de dire au Québécois
québécoises c'est quoi le projet de
société qu'on a Québec solidaire je
pense que le contraste était évident
avec un François Legault qui lui est
toujours négatif quand il parle
d'environnement à part des barrages
imaginaires là il y a rien à proposer au
Québécois québécois voyez-vous vous
m'amener la prochaine question parce que
j'ai eu l'impression que ce soit vous
avez sorti davantage la cassette que
dans le précédent débats vous avez
répété à deux reprises par exemple
monsieur Lego arrêter de sortir les
déclarations d'Halloween
ce que je me trompe dans mon analyse
c'était plus la cassette sur laquelle
vous êtes appuyé j'ai parlé avec mon
cœur ce soir comme j'ai parlé à mon avec
mon coeur l'autre soir moi je trouve ça
triste que le Québec a été gouverné
pendant quatre ans par un politicien que
si peu d'ambition si peu de vision pour
l'avenir et qui à chaque fois qu'il est
question d'environnement au lieu de dire
voici mon plan il raconte des histoires
de peur au Québécois québécois sur ce
domaine merci
je vais continuer sur ce décor
d'Halloween et cette notion de faire
peur au monde
j'ai pas l'impression que justement les
ce concepts de taxe orange de ça
commence ça commence à passer plus les
gens commencent à se dire au moins
l'impôt sur le patrimoine puis là les
véhicules énergivores vous avez pas
l'impression que ça se tourne un peu
contre vous quand même moi je pense que
à Québec solidaire on a l'avantage de la
sincérité puis de la transparence
il y a des partis politiques qui pendant
des années on dit au Québec oui oui
c'est important l'environnement
c'est absolument essentiel merci
il y a plusieurs études qui démontent
que l'adaptation changement climatique
ça va coûter encore plus cher si on
attend il faut investir massivement
maintenant
par contre l'adaptation changeant
climatique pratiquement en fait ne pas
été discuté jamais en débat c'est à
peine mentionné dans votre plateforme
électorale donc qu'est-ce que vous
comptez faire concrètement pour
aider les villes à s'adapter au
changement climatique nous on propose la
mise sur pied d'un fond d'urgence
climatique on va mettre 500 millions de
dollars par année de côté pour avoir de
l'argent quand nos enfants puis nos
petits-enfants vont devoir investir pour
faire face aux changements climatique
c'est dans notre cas de financier j'en
ai parlé à plusieurs reprises depuis le
début de la campagne je suis tout à fait
d'accord il faut à la fois lutter pour
ralentir les changements climatiques et
investir massivement pour s'adapter au
changement climatique qui vont
irrémédiablement se produire au Québec
dans une certaine proportion donc 500
milliards de 500 millions de dollars par
année
merci merci est-ce que d'autres
questions en français on va passer en
anglais alors
que pensez-vous
avoir présenté comme image quand vous
avez fait face à tant d'attaque des
attaques dures de monsieur Legault
réponse je n'ai pas été surpris que
Monsieur le goût m'attend attaqué celle
a été sa stratégie pendant tout près de
la moitié de la campagne
la révèle
quelles sont ses vrais priorités ce
n'est pas un temps de changement c'est
d'attaquer de désinformer sur le réel
programme de Québec solidaire je pense
que le Québec mérite d'être mené il y a
le gouverné par quelqu'un qui a un
projet positif pour les Québécois les
Québécoises pas uniquement quelqu'un qui
dit que le meilleur plan environnemental
est mauvais
question mais les réussit maintenant on
attend entendu les mots la taxe orange
ou les taxes oranges et cela va
peut-être vous pour le reste de la
campagne et quand les gens sont en train
de voter le 3 octobre d'autant plus
réponse je suis fier d'être le seul
leader dans notre sécurité
avec les citoyens Québécois et
Québécoises si nous voulons réussir ce
combat contre le changement climatique
on doit vraiment changer les choses on
ne peut pas uniquement dire c'est
important de combattre le réchauffement
planétaire et dire en même temps nous ne
changerons rien au Québec moi je suis
honnête je suis frein et transparent
quand je le dis au Québec au Québécois
on a besoin de changer question donc la
taxe orange quand vous dites-vous
réponse écoutez monsieur Legault aime
bien ses étiquettes je lui laisse ses
étiquettes je sais que notre plan pour
combattre le réchauffement en état et le
meilleur ce n'est pas uniquement mon
opinion c'est l'opinion de 8 experts
indépendants qui ont certifié notre plan
bonsoir question
vous a ciblé pas mal ce soir est-ce que
c'est un signe que ce que vous dites
quand à la nature du combat c'est que
c'est un peu fondé réponse monsieur Lego
semble plus intéressant à attaquer
Québec solidaire que de proposer quelque
chose de concret pour combattre le
réchauffement planétaire il y a ces
barrages imaginaires on ne sait pas où
ils seront situés comme ils vont coûter
et quand ils seront prêts je crois que
monsieur Legault a perdu son sans ses
priorité il trouve ça plus important
d'attaquer qu'avec solidaire que de
combattre le réchauffement question
étant donné la crise du logement
monsieur le Gaulle a répondu qu'il faut
créer de la richesse la prospérité au
Québec étant donné que la crise du
logement c'est aggravée depuis quelques
années est-ce que c'est une solution
réaliste réponse monsieur le goût est
complètement déconnecté de la réalité de
la crise du logement même si nous créons
plus de la vérité au Québec il nous faut
construire plus de logements abordables
des logements sociaux voilà quel devrait
être notre priorité monsieur le goût a
nié l'existence de la crise pendant des
années et ce soir il n'avait absolument
rien à offrir au Québec merci beaucoup
alors
Gabriel ado Dubois qui fait le point sur
sa performance il continue d'attaquer
monsieur Legault en effet puis mais au
centre de son argumentaire la crise
climatique et la crise du logement et
attaque même les barrages imaginaires de
monsieur Legault on accueille maintenant
Michel de retour avec nous on a quelques
minutes seulement votre évaluation avec
du débat parce qu'on a parlé dans votre
dos tantôt
bon il y a pas de clair gagnant à mon
sens dans ce débat il y en a qui ont été
meilleurs que d'autres
mais j'ai trouvé Gabriel Nadaud Dubois a
été correct mais moins extraordinaire
que la dernière fois inversement
monsieur Legault a été beaucoup moins
mauvais que la dernière fois alors dans
ce sens là je pense monsieur Legault est
content j'ai trouvé que Madame Anglade
avait fait beaucoup mieux que la
dernière fois
mordante efficace aussi
pas simple à Mondon à peu près la même
performance mais comme on a déjà été
tellement surpris la dernière fois ils
ont les moyens on s'attendait à ça je
l'ai trouvé
il devait attendre le moment où monsieur
Legault se ferait questionner sur ses
propos de la semaine dernière concernant
la lutte contre l'indépendance et
monsieur Legault était un peu pitup
là-dedans il y aurait traité incapable
de dire si votre oui ou non référendum
là il s'est rendu compte qu'il s'est mis
le pied d'embauche la semaine dernière
et si vous juste pour ce qui est de
Monsieur monsieur duham pas mauvais mais
par exemple quand il a dit écoutez on va
prendre des fonctionnaires on va les
envoyer dans les écoles
c'est pas sérieux ça se trouve que des
fois il dit des choses qui ont de
l'allure mais des fois il arrive avec
une bourde comme celle-là qui qui doit
faire dire aux gens non je voudrais pas
parce que
Valérie en attendant le retour
de Monsieur le groupe le point de presse
sur Gabriel la dose
je trouve qu'on a eu des bons échanges
entre autres sur l'équilibre entre
l'environnement puis l'économie donc
l'importance de réduire nos GES mais
sans évidemment aller vider les poches
des Québécois sans les fermer des
entreprises donc je trouve qu'on a eu un
bon échange et équilibre environnement
je pense qu'on a eu aussi des bons
échanges sur le portefeuille des
Québécois donc d'un côté il y a les
impôts mais il y a de l'aide à court
terme qui doit être donné en 2022 pour
faire face à l'inflation donc j'ai pu
répéter là que dès le mois de décembre
les Québécois vont avoir en
400$, si gagne moins de 100 000 puis les
personnes de 70 ans et plus vont avoir
un 2000 dollars de plus dès cette année
en 2022 donc je pense que de façon
générale bon on a parlé aussi de santé
on a parlé
d'éducation on a parlé de la protection
du français donc j'ai aimé les échanges
qu'on a eu très content on va prendre
une question pour donner la chance à
tout le monde première question monsieur
Saint-Pierre playmondon c'est attaqué à
vos seuils d'immigration parce que vous
avez admis qu'un chiffre 50 000
contribués au recul du français
qu'est-ce que vous comptez mettre en
œuvre pour éviter que ce soit le cas
dans le passé puis c'est ce que j'ai dit
Monsieur saint-pierre-la-mondon c'est
autant un gouvernement du véhicule qu'un
gouvernement libéral et ont accepté 50%
des immigrants choisis par le Québec par
le pas français nous l'année dernière il
y en avait seulement 20% en ont réussi à
en avoir 80% qui parlaient français
avant d'être choisi va falloir continuer
dans cette direction-là d'avoir un plus
grand pourcentage
est-ce que vous vous engagez à le
maintenir à 80%. c'est notre objectif
oui effectivement ça c'est réaliste oui
on pense que c'est réaliste entre autres
en visant les régions en visant les
étudiants qui viennent étudier dans les
collèges les universités francophone
donc moi j'étais à l'aise avec le 50 000
je pars à l'aise du tout avec le 70000
puis 80000 de Québec soldat du Parti
libéral mais avec le 50000 si on choisit
bien nos immigrants qui sont
sélectionnés par Québec si on exige de
connaître le français pour la grande
majorité je pense qu'on est capable d'y
arriver prochaine question
bonsoir bonsoir est-ce que vous traitez
mal les femmes ben écoutez ça met un peu
choqué cette attaque là qui revient
souvent de la part de Madame Anglade
parce qu'avec Sonia Lebel on ne fait
tellement pour les femmes là écoutez je
le rappelle c'était la première fois
dans l'histoire du Québec qu'on a donné
des augmentations de salaire
différenciées puis ces trois groupes de
femmes qui ont eu des augmentations
je vais venir d'abord commençons par
dire qu'on a augmenté les salades et
préposés aux initiales qui sont surtout
des femmes ici éducatrices en garderie
qui sont surtout des femmes que les
enseignants qui sont sortis maintenant
madame anglais des garderies je trouve
que tellement mal placé parler des
garderies parce que d'abord rappelons
que le gouvernement libéral avait mis
une taxe on s'en rappelle il y avait
augmenté le tarif des garderies nous on
le remis à un tarif unique en or baissé
on corriger l'erreur des libéraux que
les libéraux à cause de Tony Tomassi
avait 12 étapes ça prenait cinq ans pour
créer une place on a corrigé ça aussi
donc je trouve que même en anglais
tellement mal placé pour faire ce genre
d'accusation prochaine question bonsoir
monsieur Legault le soleil je repose la
question de Monsieur dumm sur le
troisième lien qui fait l'étude et
combien coûte-t-elle bon c'est le bureau
de projet ok le bureau de projet et géré
par des fonctionnaires et par des
consultants qui font faire les études
donc c'est pas le politique c'est que de
ça c'est bureau de projet même pas
répondu sur le coup je vais imposer une
deuxième question encore sur le
troisième lien on a parlé beaucoup dans
les derniers temps pourquoi vous êtes
que je vous ai pas répondu sur le coup
je vous ai demandé combien
je vais aussi poser ma deuxième question
si vous me permettez on en a parlé
beaucoup du troisième lien aussi bon au
début on avait une étude on voulait pas
la sortir après ça on avait plus
d'études
est-ce que le troisième livre est en
train de devenir la pas du tout parce
que d'abord les études qui ont été
faites c'est sur un lien à l'est à six
voix là nous ce qu'on propose depuis un
an suite au consultation c'est un tunnel
4 voies centre-ville à centre-ville qui
va beaucoup aider le transport collectif
puisqu'il fait pas mal consensus à
Québec et à Lévy on va prendre pour la
question prochaine question si vous
voulez pas ça merci
bonjour
Est-ce que vous estimez au terme de
votre performance de votre débat que
vous méritez les quatre années que vous
demandez au Québécois ben écoutez stocké
quoi de répondre à ça là je veux pas
prendre la décision le 3 octobre on va
avoir la réponse de Québécois j'espère
qu'ils vont me donner leurs confiance on
a remarqué ce soir que j'avais fait
beaucoup d'attaques contre Monsieur
Nadou Dubois est-ce que vous êtes en
train de valider ici
ces prétentions sont laquelle c'est une
course seulement à deux c'est parce
qu'on est pardon on est tous au Québec
d'accord qu'il faut lutter contre les
changements climatiques qu'on a besoin
d'un plan costaud pour réduire les GES
mais quand monsieur Nadaud Dubois dit
qui veut mettre une taxe orange de 7500
dollars qui veut augmenter la dette de
40%, puis qui veut fermer des
entreprises là Monsieur Nadou du bois un
peu comme au pays des merveilles et je
pense les Québécois doivent comprendre
ça est-ce que vous confirmez c'est une
course à deux comme écoutez là-dessus là
sur le plan pour réduire les GES
c'est comme de la magie monsieur Nadaud
Dubois c'est le fun moi aussi j'aimerais
ça aller vite comme lui mais ça se peut
pas faut le dire il faut l'expliquer il
nous reste un peu moins de 2 minutes en
français Marco oui bonsoir monsieur
Legault à quoi servira l'étude sur le
troisième lien qui a été commandé au
bureau de projet mais ça va nous aider
techniquement avoir qu'est-ce que c'est
exactement la meilleure façon de procède
des l'entrée les sorties
lachalandage prévu le pourcentage qui
sera mis pour le transport collectif le
pourcentage qui se remis pour les autos
éventuellement qui seront électriques
donc c'est un peu tout ça qu'on va avoir
dans l'étude mais peu importe les
conclusions vous allez aller de l'avant
avec la console quand j'ai dit ça c'est
comme disait ouais si l'étude nous dit
que ça prend une autoroute sur l'île
d'Orléans mais je m'excuse là j'accepte
très pas de mettre une autoroute sur
l'île d'Orléans là c'est là que j'ai dit
il y aura une décision politique
là-dessus qui a été le meilleur le logo
de la semaine dernière ou logo de ce
soir et pourquoi ben je pense peut-être
bonne humeur cette semaine et j'étais de
bonne humeur surtout quand je parlais de
mes idées mais évidemment comme vous
l'avez vu me fait beaucoup attaquer donc
là dans ce temps-là je souris moins une
dernière en français bonjour monsieur
Lego vous a quand même sentiment patient
à certains moments dans ce débat est-ce
que vous trouvez vraiment que votre
performance était meilleur que la
semaine dernière
mais j'ai essayé en tout cas de passer
plus mes idées donc c'est jamais facile
de trouver l'équilibre entre être
défensif sur les nombreuses attaques et
être offensif en disant voici ce que la
carte propose parce que il faut qu'il y
a un équilibre dans le temps que les
quatre chefs m'attaquaient moins vous
avez un autre adversaire monsieur dum
que vous s'attaquez peu vous êtes plutôt
concentré sur Gabriel Nadaud Dubois
pourquoi l'attaquer seulement sur la
pandémie monsieur dum je pense que ici
comme disqualifié irrégué
il n'y a pas été solidaire de nos aînés
il y a agi un peu comme quelqu'un qui
profite la situation pour aller chercher
des votes je pense irresponsable c'est
inquiétant et c'est pour ça que les
Québécois s'attendent d'un leader donc
je pense c'était important le puis je
pense que sur ce sujet là ça le
disqualifie on a du temps pour une en
anglais file
bonsoir monsieur
qu'avez-vous pensé en passant est-ce que
vous êtes plus amusé ce soir réponse oui
pourquoi réponse parce que j'ai eu
plusieurs questions de proposer des
choses
plutôt que d'uniquement répondre
[Musique]
leader
comme la semaine dernière et ils étaient
vraiment légué contre moi mais moi
j'étais en mesure peut-être un lien avec
le format j'ai été plus en mesure de
proposer question
et qu'avez-vous pensé de l'accusation
que vous essayez d'éteindre le mouvement
souveraineté réponse écoutez comme je
l'ai dit la souveraineté va toujours
être une grande idée mais le problème
c'est que maintenant ce n'est pas une
priorité pour la majorité des Québécois
voilà c'est tout merci tout le monde
bonne nuit
il y en a plusieurs qui vont bien dormir
cette nuit sans doute la question est
revenue souvent est-ce que monsieur
Legault traitement ou bien les femmes
écoutant madame andlade en échange avec
Monsieur Lebeau
sous votre gouverne il y a eu un recul
pour les femmes un recul important non
mais c'est pas une blague vous dites
c'est pas une blague
merci merci un recul pour les femmes
pourquoi parce qu'on a des femmes mais
non mais c'est sérieux c'est sérieux il
y a des femmes aujourd'hui qui ne
peuvent pas retourner sur le marché du
travail parce qu'elles n'ont pas de
service de garde
alors qui veut commenter Guillaume je
trouve vraiment que c'est un échange qui
était très efficace et de la part de
Madame Anglade je le disais tout à
l'heure mais l'espèce de solidarité tout
le monde pour dire monsieur le goût
laissez-la parler c'était parlant
justement puis madame Anglade de
l'expliquer un peu dans son point de
presse tout à l'heure mais c'est que
François Legault revient toujours aux
augmentations salariales qui le
consentie et ça c'est vrai mais il y a
autre chose que ça c'est un peu je pense
le point qu'elle a réussi à bien faire
valoir les questions de charge mentale
notamment
et là dessus elle a marqué quelques
points maintenant
interviewé par Patrice est venu dire
aussi et celle qui est là depuis deux
ans qui sont à quitté la profession et
l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur donc on
a beau avoir des augmentations de
salaire si les conditions de
s'améliorent pas il pourrait y avoir des
gens qui parlent mais Monsieur le goût
assez a répondu mais on a embauché 2000
ergothérapeutes tout terrain de
différents pour de différents services
mais c'est pas les inventer c'est genre
elle frappe partout et puis les les gens
poussent pas dans les arbres et je
monsieur Legault veut pénaliser les
femmes n'osent pas ça du tout l'idée
mais il se trouve que les catégories
d'emploi qui sont actuellement les plus
difficiles sont occupés par des femmes
on les enseignants les
les infirmières bien sûr les éducatrices
en garderie et il est un fait que
généralement le problème de garde quand
tu trouves pas
c'est la femme qui esprit avec ce
problème les familles se ruinent à payer
les garderies privées non souvent alors
madame madame Anglade en fait ramasser
le groupe personnellement responsable de
persécution c'est un peu fort mais la
réalité est qu'effectivement il y a des
problèmes qui sont pas réglés et qui
affectent d'abord les faire Valérie oui
mais effectivement c'est aussi
j'aimerais que c'est des échanges
complètement
pour Madame anglaise qui avait promis
justement cette espèce de leadership
différent alors cette partie là
est vraiment de dire je suis une chef
femme je suis la seule des quatre des
cinq est une femme à travers quatre
cravates donc il y avait ce côté-là
je suis très satisfait du débat j'ai
beaucoup aimé nos échanges ce soir ça a
permis de mettre en lumière évidemment
la plateforme électorale notamment du
Parti conservateur du Québec j'ai
particulièrement apprécié les échanges
avec monsieur Legault au sujet du
troisième lien j'ai été fort surpris
comme vous j'imagine de voir qu'il ne
savait pas qui allait faire l'étude dont
il parle depuis plusieurs jours il
n'avait aucune idée de combien ça allait
coûter non plus donc il nous promet il
nous a avoué il y a quelques jours qui
avait pas d'études il nous avoue
aujourd'hui que il sait il sait pas qui
va faire l'étude mais il sait qu'il va
il s'est déjà la conclusion puis c'est
quand l'étude va être publiée il sait
pas combien va coûter ça de ça ça
devient de plus en plus complexe et de
plus en plus un nébuleux cette histoire
de troisième lien dans la bouche de
monsieur Legault c'est c'est aussi en
contradiction avec certaines des
déclarations qui avaient faites
antérieurement puis comme j'ai comme
vous j'imagine aussi constater ce soir
qu'il ne veut toujours pas rendre public
les études qui le déjà en main sous
prétexte que ce sont des études qui
parlent d'un pont à l'Est qui est
exactement la proposition du Parti
conservateur du Québec et celle que
proposer il y a 4 ans monsieur Legault
donc je pense que Monsieur le goût est
en train de de d'attirer beaucoup
l'attention sur cet enjeu-là
particulièrement pour la grande région
de Québec en vue du scrutin du 3 octobre
prochain sur ce ça va maintenant me
faire plaisir de prendre vos questions
pour la période de questions on aura un
dix minutes donc si possible vous
contentez d'un d'une question puis d'une
question je pense que vos collègues
apprécieront également 8 minutes pour
question en français puis ensuite on
passera vos questions en anglais merci
bonsoir Tayeb moi le journal de
québecs les plus vigoureux là de la
soirée du débat était concernant la
pandémie monsieur le goût vous a traité
d'agitateur d'irresponsable là je le
cite il y a quelques minutes il a dit
que vous êtes dis vérifier et puis la
paru fâché il a quasiment là contre
contre vous pendant 7% là comment vous
l'avez vécu ce bout là du débat ben j'ai
été très étonné de Monsieur le goût du
moment où il y a choisi d'aborder cet
enjeu là on parlait de santé mentale si
vous rappelez bien le l'objet du débat
au moment où monsieur Legault est sauté
dans la reine et là il y a des idées de
se mettre à m'attaquer sur les aînés et
la crise sanitaire
c'est la crise de la santé mentale de je
respirais que je lis même dit pendant
que des boxs beaucoup moins partisans je
pense que tout le monde ici est à même
de constater que yo au Québec il va y
avoir un problème de santé mentale il y
a des études qui commencent à documenter
le problème le problématique que ça va
que ça va que ça va développer que lui
se servent de ça pour commencer à dire
que on avait abandonné les années
j'ai trouvé ça un peu bizarre parce que
ceux et celles qui vont souffrir
beaucoup de santé mentale il y a des
années évidemment mais il y a surtout
aussi beaucoup de jeunes et ça a été ça
mais mon point puis essayer de le je
comprends qu'il y a de la difficulté à
défendre sa crise Center puis il sentait
au d'un besoin le délai de de défendre
son bilan à ce niveau là je veux juste
vous rappeler que par rapport à la gare
de chiffres je sais qu'une grosse gare
de chiffres est-ce que plus ou moins de
marque que hier au Canada père capita il
y a eu plus de morts au Québec que
partout ailleurs au Canada monsieur
Legault se sert toujours de la l'indice
de la surmortalité qui n'a jamais
utilisé en passant pendant les premières
années de la crise il y a toujours parlé
de mort puis de mort par centaines de
milliers d'habitants il a changé la
méthodologie pour que maintenant il y
ait des chiffres qui fasse un peu mieux
paraître mais à la limite c'est pas ça
c'est pas ça l'enjeu aujourd'hui le
l'enjeu c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
les enfants qui souffrent il y a une
étude Université de Sherbrooke qui nous
dit que près de 50% des enfants des
jeunes ont des problèmes d'anxiété ont
des problèmes de dépression moi c'est ça
qui m'interpelle et là-dessus
malheureusement monsieur Legault a pas
commencé à avoir le début du
commencement d'une réponse et évidemment
que le fait que le que sur confinés ça a
eu un impact encore plus dévastateur sur
la santé mentale des Québécois vous avez
évoqué en début de débat la question du
pont de Québec oui comment vous voyez
les choses maintenant sachant il y a une
entente entre le fédéral et le CN le
gouvernement du Québec n'est pas encore
dans cette entente le négociateur accusé
le gouvernement de faire de la petite
politique comment vous il y a pas eu de
réponse la nature puis le temps presse
c'est d'ici la fin du mois dans quelques
jours on parle c'est même des heures
avant la fin de l'Entente le
gouvernement du Québec c'est traîner les
pieds de toute évidence dans ce dossier
là comme dans le dossier de tous les
liens avec la réussite de Québec
regardez ce qui se passe avec le Pont
Pierre Laporte il veut toujours pas nous
dire c'est quoi le problème pourquoi
Pomerlo a enlevé d'urgence les
équipements sur le Pont Pierre Laporte
on sait que il y a des problèmes avec
les suspentes du Pont Pierre Laporte ils
veulent pas donner leur jus s'il y a pas
tout est au œil de ce côté là le pont de
Québec les négociations le gouvernement
du Québec de toute évidence se traîne
vérifier et pas très responsable dans ce
dossier là et en plus de ça son
troisième lien qui nous avait promis il
y a 4 ans il y a pas commencé les
travaux contrairement à ce que certains
de ces députés avaient promis pire que
ça il nous dit qu'il y a tant une étude
l'an prochain puis on y arrive dans un
débat puis même pas foutu de nous dire
qui fait l'étude puis même pas foutu
nous dire combien va coûter cette étude
mais il sait déjà les conclusions de
l'étude c'est hallucinant
oui bonsoir Monsieur James
il y a un thème que auquel vous tenez
beaucoup qui celui du privé en santé
est-ce que vous êtes satisfait de la
place qui a été donnée à ce thème-là des
échanges que vous avez eu là-dessus dans
le cas du débat mais je pense que ça a
mis en relief la différence entre le
Parti conservateur du Québec et les
quatre autres parties je crois qu'il y a
une grosse différence sur comment on
peut ajouter j'ai été content parce que
même il y a même une question de
l'animateur sur la spécifiquement sur la
place du privé en santé
j'ai particulièrement mis la échange
avec Monsieur Nadaud Dubois c'était gare
là qui qui lui disait que s'il y a une
impression que le privé
omniprésent selon ses propres désirs
alors que c'est pas c'est pas du tout
notre perception je pense que les
téléspectateurs ont une meilleure
compréhension j'ai aussi pu exprimer
parce que dans le premier débat il y
avait de la confusion puis je m'étais
même ici quand il y a eu 5 chefs un
débat il y a quelques semaines aussi on
comparaissait ou à ce qui se passait aux
États-Unis tout ça aujourd'hui j'ai
vraiment eu la chance vous expliquer non
non la carte d'assurance maladie du
Québec va demeurer vous allez pouvoir
aller au public ou au privé s'il y a pas
des délais raisonnables donc ça nous a
vraiment permis de rappeler que ça se
fait à l'intérieur de la Loi canadienne
sur la santé puis qu'on respecte
l'assurance publique donc ça je suis
très très content le qu'on ait pu mais
c'est au clair le pire notre position
puis comparer ça au modèle européen qui
nous ont inspiré notamment la Suède et
l'Allemagne prochaine question peut-être
non juste pour discipline ambiguïté
puisque vous avez comme opposé les
possibles d'essai d'aimer à la santé
mentale des jeunes est-ce qu'on doit
comprendre que pour préserver la santé
mentale des jeunes pendant la pandémie
ça aurait été justifiée d'exposer des
années à des dangers en réduisant le
nombre de mesures sanitaires c'est pas
moi qui a posé ça c'est Monsieur
Lego qui est sauté dans la mairie alors
qu'on parlait de santé mentale des
enfants qui a commencé à parler des
morts puis des années merci beaucoup
madame
position
le moi j'ai jamais parlé des c'est lui
qui a commencé à m'attaquer là dessus
alors qu'on parlait de la santé mentale
des plus jeunes monsieur Laberge merci
bonjour Thomas Laberge pour le soleil
bonjour monsieur duem vous parlez bon
beaucoup de privé de concurrence on a un
peu l'impression que pour tous les
problèmes dont on fait face à ceci dit
québécoises c'est un peu toujours la
même solution que vous proposez est-ce
que c'est vrai non quand j'ai parlé du
des ponts on a parlé moi je pense que
l'échange le plus important ce soir ce
qui était le plus révélateur je pense
que c'est surtout sur le troisième lien
Québec Lévis il n'était pas question de
priver versus public le c’était
clairement des travaux qui sont faits de
façon publique donc il y a pas eu de on
était pas mono sujet à ce niveau-là je
ne pense pas quand on est des échanges
la santé mentale dont on vient de parler
avec Madame porter c'était pas non plus
un débat entre le privé le public c'est
là où il était question du privé
effectivement c'est en matière de santé
puis c'est sûr qu'il y a même un peu en
matière d'éducation aussi c'est vrai
qu'un certain moment il était question
du privé mais en tant que conservateur
c'est notre philosophie politique nous
on croit à la libre concurrence on pense
que effectivement quand il y a plusieurs
joueurs puis qui se font
ultimement c'est le patient l'enfant le
contribuable qui en sort gagnant on ne
croit pas à des gros monopoles qui
soient publics ou privés en passant
c'est pas juste les prix les publics
donc on j'ai pu mettre ça en relief
peut-être ce soir un peu plus que dans
le premier débat là-dessus vous avez
raison merci beaucoup monsieur Laberge
madame Crète j'ai posé une seule
question je suis le temps file
est-ce que vous voulez faire du 3e année
la question de l'homme vous avez ça
beaucoup de l'avant allez dernier jour
mais c'est c'est évident que c'est une
question très importante c'est de loin
le plus gros investissement de
l'histoire de la ville de Québec c'est
la question qui qui fait je pense qu'il
est qu'interpelle le plus les électeurs
ce filtre à moi je vous avouer là il y a
la question de l'inflation c'est au
niveau de la grandeur du Québec mais
dans la région de Québec j'ai encore
fait du porte-à-porte en fin de semaine
c'est clair et net que la question qui
interpelle les gens de Québec c'est le
tramway et le troisième bien je sais pas
quel pourcentage la population va voter
une fonction du troisième lien ou du
tramway mais je pense que c'est un très
fort pourcentage ça se repose 100% que
la question référendum c'est un peu un
piège parce que c'est pas 100% des gens
et des gens qui m'ont voté sur d'autres
enjeux mais c'est certainement l'enjeu
régional et de loin qui va retenir le
plus l'attention de la population de
Québec ça c'est bien évidemment
en anglais bonsoir
question
vous avez beaucoup parlé du troisième
lien entre Québec et Lévy mais pour les
Montréal et les Montréalais
vous craindre que les gens vont vous
voir comme un parti de la vie capitale
partie de Montréal réponse écoutez c'est
le plus gros budget de longue date alors
c'est devenu une question nationale en
lien avec la peur de la dépense
bon mais c'est déjà quand même qui
prennent posture
presque pédagogique sur son programme et
content de la formule lui aussi je
trouve ça très symptomatique ou
symbolique qui les fait ses premières et
ses premières phrases avant les
questions des journalistes sur le
troisième siège uniquement et ça ça
démontre je pense la conclusion à
laquelle on en vient c'est que ce soit
il a pas réussi à élargir son auditoire
et indduel trop effacé passer dans son
programme et qu'il revienne avec le
troisième lien ça c'est pour mousser ses
candidats dans Bose Nord bossud et sa
propre candidature dans showroom
le choix des extraits sur cette histoire
là
peut-être l'extrait Duhem caca
qui détruirait l'île d'Orléans
c'est la bonne idée on a besoin d'un
lien on propose un tunnel monsieur
[Musique]
un tunnel centre-ville centre-ville 4
voies ça fait un premier temps que je
promets aujourd'hui mais monsieur
Legault on évolue tout le monde évolue
oui vous avez évolué vous avez abandonné
les gens de la région
que Valérie rapidement en attendant que
Monsieur saberge de montré arrive mais
rapidement il a quand même fait mouche
je me suis dit avec sa question sur qui
fait l'étude et combien coûte parce que
il a répondu on y revient à Monsieur
Saint-
vous avez dit Monsieur le goût essaye de
d'éteindre le débat de la souveraineté
avez-vous l'impression que ce soir vous
êtes parvenu à rallumer vous ce bol
ben ça le mérite de créer un choix qui
est important qui mérite une réflexion à
savoir moi je veux relancer
l'indépendantiste mais je pense qu'on
devrait décider par nous-mêmes au Québec
qu'on devrait exister à l'international
François le groupe pense l'inverse
puis lui il veut faire plus de demandes
toujours les mêmes au Canada on sait
tous c'est quoi le résultat là qui nous
attend mais
c'est un choix et c'est un choix qui
doit être soumis à l'électeurs parce que
ça a beaucoup d'incidence sur l'avenir
du Québec avez-vous l'impression que
c'est vous qui rallumez ce débat ou on a
l'impression qu'il y ait aussi Québec
solidaire est-ce que vous avez laissé
peut-être la place à Québec solidaire
dans ce débat ce soir il y a de la place
pour tout le monde mais je pense que
c'est l'actualité ce sont les deux
points quelques milliards qu'on envoie
dans les sables bitumineux de l'alberto
a même nos impôts les 6 milliards
manquants l'absence de contrôle et de
pouvoir en culture sur nos frontières
l'absence d'application de nos lois sur
les entreprises à Chartres fédéral la
loi 101 sur notre territoire à
s'applique pas l'absence d'application
de nos lois d'environnement il y a
l'actualité nous ramène constamment
l'existence d'un gouvernement de trop
moi je pense que c'est légitime et super
nécessaire de mentionner qu'on devrait
et qu'on un jour on décidera par
nous-mêmes comme n'importe quel pays
normal
bonjour bonjour
est-ce que c'est ce soir que les
souverainistes de la CAQ rentrent au
Bergheim
j'ai voulu est-ce que vous avez réussi à
les convaincre c'est quand même simple
oui puis je leur ai pas parlé peut-être
vous je sais pas
moi j'ai voulu mener un débat sur
certaines questions essentielles avec
authenticité en donnant leur juste et
sur l'indépendance comme sur le français
François Legault avait pas de réponse à
mes interventions il n'avait pas d'autre
plan que de continuer dans un déclin de
la langue française qui est marqué
continue dans des échecs répétés avec le
fédéral donc ce sont des questions
légitimes et j'espère que j'en conviens
des gens qui sont indépendantistes de
revenir dans leur maison parce que la
porte est grande ouverte c'est la maison
du Parti québécois et est-ce que ça
c'est ce soir que vous pensez que vous
avez réussi à gagner votre propre
circonscription
je vais pas faire d'analyse je me suis
concentré à être moi-même puis être
clair sur les enjeux qui sont
déterminants à mes yeux pour notre
avenir
bonjour bonjour
vous avez des non seulement d'accord
avec sur le bien des sujets du bois mais
vous avez même sablé faire équipe avec
lui pour attaquer François Legault
qu'est-ce que ça vous donne de faire ça
je vais faire équipe avec Dominique
Anglade quand François Legault essayait
de lui couper la parole sur un sujet
fondamental je me suis montré ouvert à
tout le monde parce que notre but c'est
d'intéresser le plus possible les gens
la politique essentiellement obtenir
aussi un taux de participation élevé aux
élections puis il y a une manière de
faire de la politique pour que les gens
continuent à écouter s'intéressent à
l'avenir moi j'ai trouvé que pour la
démocratie c'est un débat qui était
simple puis
il y a pas de stratégie au-delà de ce
que vous pensez que les Québécois il
apprécient
des débats comme ceux-là sur cette des
réflexions puis de l'intérêt parce que
c'est notre avenir donc question ce sont
de vraies questions quand on parle de
nos tout-petits de la dignité des aînés
les soins de santé l'avenir de notre
langue c'est tout des vrais choses des
choses importantes pour la suite pour
l'avenir
Debois dans vos publicités vous dites
que vous voulez réveiller le géant
endormi de l'indépendance c'est le
mouvement en fait qui est le géant notre
mouvement est un géant avez-vous réussi
à réveiller ou du moins
le sortir un peu de son sommeil ce soir
mais il est occupé de l'espace
normalement quand quelque chose dort on
le voit pas
il est occupé de l'espace parce que
lorsque je pose des questions pourtant
simple sur le français et sur notre
rapport avec Ottawa François Legault
change le sujet ou offre des réponses
qui sont les mêmes réponses qui ont
échoué au cours des quatre dernières
années donc c'est certain que il est là
la question elle est là elle est entière
et elle est légitime elle est
fondamentale elle dure depuis les
patriotes c'est le combat de c'est la
lutte légitime de René Lévesque de plein
de gens qui ont beaucoup donné pour une
cause qui demeure d'actualité et qui a
mes yeux est déterminante pour l'avenir
du Québec comme vous avez
parlé à monsieur Legault du de ces
propos sur le monopole d'un compte la
souveraineté
semblait nier avoir dit ça au dernier
débat comment vous vous interprétez se
repositionnement là
je sais pas mais de toute évidence
il avait volontairement oublié ses
propos pourtant tellement clair de qui
essentiellement le métier de l'avant
comme le chef le plus fédéraliste de
tous les chefs donc ensuite on peut
essayer de jouer sur les mots dire j'ai
pas dit ça il y avait des points 5
millions de téléspectateurs la semaine
dernière puis il y avait probablement
l'équivalent donc les gens suivent ça
puis
ils attirent les conclusions mais ce que
vous vous interprétez ça comme un chef
qui essaie de remettre la pâte à dents
dans le tube je vais laisser les
analystes faire cette
[Musique]
exercice là mais il est clair que
il tentait de nier les propos qui l'ont
tenus la semaine dernière alors que tout
le monde en a été témoin je vais poser
juste une question je vais laisser du
temps à mes collègues anglophones
à la lumière de bottes ce soir est-ce
que François Legault vote oui ou non un
référendum s'il y en a un prochain il y
a pas de transparence
il y en a pas juste sur cette question
là
le déclin du français arrive quoi il
continue les mêmes politiques que ce qui
nous amène dans le déclin le plus
accéléré de l'histoire du Québec il y a
pas de réponse transparente de la part
de François Legault
bonsoir
pensez-vous que ce soit
parce que vous avez
sorti une bonne quand vous avez accusé
monsieur Legault de vouloir éteindre le
moteur et Madame Anglade ne l'a pas dit
la semaine dernière mais ce soir elle a
dit je suis fédéraliste avec un filtre
moderne pensez-vous que les électeurs
qui sont chez lac maintenant qu'ils
soient fait le reste ou les vôtres des
indépendants des touristes pensez-vous
qu'ils vont retourner à leur partie
d'origine est-ce que cela va changer un
peu l'échiquier réponse écoutez
manifestement il n'y a qu'un seul parti
qui est engagé sur la voie de
l'indépendance Québec il y a un seul
parti qui dit qui a déclin du français
on veut le l'inverser avec des mesures
proportionnelles à ce défi il n'y a que
seul partie donc bien sûr je pense que
les gens vont y réfléchir ils vont dire
si je crois que le Québec devrait
décider pour lui-même
il y a une option
on peut voter selon ce que l'on pense
car en 2018 beaucoup de souverainistes
ont voté pour le CAC pour remplacer les
libéraux cela a déjà été fait c'est du
passé alors je pense que les gens sont
maintenant dans une autre mouvance à
savoir voter selon leurs opinions leur
conviction politique
question
bonsoir
beaucoup de vos solutions
sont fondés sur l'indépendance on va
pouvoir contrôler nos frontières de
combattre le réchauffement planétaire
améliorer notre système de santé mais
admettons que nous réussissions le coût
et qu'on devient indépendant et qu'on a
un gouvernement comme celui de François
Legault dans une nation indépendante
est-ce que ça va régler les problèmes
réponse oui car les intérêts ne sont
plus les mêmes oui bien sûr dans une
démocratie les gens ont des débats font
des choix mais le principe fondamental
de démocratie c'est que les gens sur
certains territoires devraient décéder
pour eux-mêmes par eux-mêmes et voilà ce
n'est pas le cas pour le Québec au
Canada et ensuite vous avez des conflits
d'intérêts des intérêts qui sont
concurrentiels l'Alberta a des intérêts
dans le pétrole et les gaz et nous
n'avons aucun
intérêts à faire la transition vers la
nouvelle économie afin se développer un
avantage qu'on peut être sur le plan
mondial donc les intérêts ne sont pas
les mêmes et le principe fondamental
demeure on devrait décider pour
nous-mêmes selon nos débats nous un jeu
nous intéresse
une question
ça a été un peu plus polique vous
adversaire est-ce que ça fonctionne pour
vous réponse ma stratégie c'est d'être
moi-même et d'être aussi clair et
pertinent que possible sur certains
enjeux fondementaux et essentiel pour
notre avenir et voilà ce que j'ai fait
je pense que c'est ce que j'ai tenté de
faire et je veux intéresser les gens le
plus grand nombre de gens sur les choix
de l'avenir qui nous attendent merci
cinquième et dernier chef à tenir ce
point de presse d'après débat pour
rappeler ce qu'ils ont défendu au cours
des deux dernières heures écoutez la
question qui est revenue beaucoup ce
soir et là un des journalistes posent
une question monsieur Saint-Pierre les
analyses répondre à ça on les a avec
nous les analyses si cette fameuse
question du référendum monsieur Lego
votre style oui ou non on va voici
l'échange dont il est question et on
analyse après
ce que je conclue là c'est demain matin
il y avait un référendum pour répondre à
votre question à ma gauche ce serait oui
ce serait oui avec Québec solidaire ce
serait mes billes avec le Parti
conservateur puis peut-être avec avec
monsieur Legault avec nous ce serait non
le choix est clair on est parti
fédéraliste et j'aimerais juste préciser
quand on dit quand on dit parti
fédéralisme ça veut pas dire s'écraser
par rapport à Ottawa ça veut dire être
un partenaire un partenaire et pas un
adversaire c'est pas tout à fait
l'extrait qu'on voulait vous présenter
parce que c'est un extrait où monsieur
Legault hésitait il répondait pas en
fait
c'est le silence de Monsieur
fait qu'on le retrouvera l'excès comme
quoi vous le présenter Valérie là-dessus
est-ce que c'est un enjeu important qui
pour ce soir ben on a vu que ça le débat
de la semaine dernière sur l'histoire
vous n'avez plus le monopole on voit que
ça ça rebondit ce soir encore
on dit depuis le début de la campagne il
Martel on avait l'impression un peu un
peu seul sur son île au tout début de la
campagne avec ce thème mais force est
d'admettre aux deux tiers de la campagne
il se maintient ce soir il a martelé et
c'est vrai que c'est dans tous les
thèmes
le français les seuils d'immigration la
souveraineté sur la solution
l'environnement la souveraineté donc qui
est arrivé à placer son cette solution
jusqu'au serment de la reine de cette
question un peu amusante à la fin de ta
belle-fille est-ce que donc les
souverainistes qui se sont logés à la
CAQ en 2018 pour battre les libéraux on
voulait tout hein sauf les libéraux là
c'est la question qu'on se pose avant le
débat Michel ce qui peuvent être
influencés ce soir par le type bon ça
sera pas la question de l'urne on
s'entend mais oui c'est important pour
pour le PQ pour une opposition aussi oui
mais pour le PQ c'est essentiellement
parce que honnêtement dans l'ensemble de
la population je pense pas que c'est une
priorité immédiate mais pour le PQ je
pense c'est très réussi d'avoir réussi à
embarrasser monsieur Legault là-dessus
il faut se reporter au débat de la
semaine dernière monsieur Legault dans
le cours du débat dit à Madame Anglade
vous n'avez plus le monopole de la lutte
contre l'indépendance autrement dit
monsieur Legault qui était avant ça un
autonomie nationaliste le devient
fédéraliste et même un défenseur de
l'unité canadienne c'est tout profit
pour le PQ qui se dit ah je vais
rapatrier les kakis qui comme le disait
monsieur le comme était la question
tantôt à ce qui ces gens-là qui ont voté
pour la CAC pour battre les libéraux
maintenant que c'est réglé vont-ils
revenir au PQ il y en a une partie qui
vont revenir au PQ il y en a même qui
sont des nationalistes qui s'inquiète
pour l'avenir du français qui vont se
dire de toute façon il y en aura pas de
référendum le PQ a pas de chance de
rentrer au pouvoir alors donnons donc
renflouerons donc PQ ça ne peut qu'être
bon et je pense que oui ça peut
fonctionner ça ça donnera pas 25 sièges
au pécule
ça donne de
[Musique]
le Parti québécois mais pour le Parti
québécois c'est important d'aller
chercher ces gens-là à la coalition à
venir Québec justement pour se renflouer
et c'est ça l'enjeu de l'extrait qu'on
vient de voir il y a un autre extrait
Sébastien que vous aviez choisi c'est
l'extrait pspp et monsieur Legault oui
madame monsieur le troisième lien j'ai
pris beaucoup de temps dans le temps de
l'environnement
politiques vous alliez le faire c'est ce
que vous avez déclaré donc un moment
donné
études pour études il procède pour des
raisons électoralistes et à tous les
gens traversent le Québec ça vous dit à
quel point les décisions de la CAQ sont
peu-fondées sur l'intérêt public et
pendant ce temps-là il y a des projets
de transport structurant dans l'est de
Montréal qui ont pas avancé pendant
quatre ans il y a un pont à Tadoussac
pour lequel on a déjà 14 études et
laquelle 14 études depuis 1973 puis vous
en voulez une autre pour celui-là mais
le troisième lien par exemple sur pas de
problème 8 10 12 milliards c'est parti
par souci de cohérence parce que au
début de l'émission j'ai parlé de
Dominique England performé encore je
trouvais que ça illustré bien à quel
point monsieur saint-pierre-la-mondon
est capable de passer son message
envoyer aussi monsieur Legault encaissé
et essayer de sourire c'était
probablement au début du débat parce que
à la fin du débat il sourit un peu moins
mais dans cet extrait là vous avez les
deux objectifs que chacun voulait
atteindre d'une certaine façon pas
simple à mon don prendre de la place se
faire connaître sur ses arguments et
monsieur Legault qui essayait
d'encaisser tout en sourire
je me suis Saint-Pierre Plamondon était
efficace là-dessus parce qu'on se
demande beaucoup où sont les études à
quel prix sont encore valides ou quoi
mais au final ça monsieur Lego le 17
semaines ça va revenir à une décision
politique et essentiellement et ils
mettaient le droit exactement sur le sur
le beau boulet et oui c'est le troisième
lien Anne-Marie
régional
ça touche l'étalement urbain ça touche
toute la vie publique de dollars mais
tous les ingrédients pour en devenir un
gros
qu'est-ce que vous avez vu là-dedans
Valérie Iria votre pont
il semblait que j'avais vu vous dans ce
non verbal de monsieur Legault même si
des sources
je disais je vais pas me citer moi-même
bien entendu mais je disais faire
attention de pas être ok François
fâche-toi pas sourire il y avait un peu
de ça ça faisait un petit peu artificiel
de dire ah je suis capable d'encaisser
alors évidemment c'était je pense que
c'est il se rappelait à ce moment-là il
y avait quelque chose d'un peu amusé moi
par contre je vous avouer que l'étude ce
sur quoi c'est arrivé c'est à dire il y
a eu 14 études dans votre dossier j'ai
peut-être qu'elle était un spectateurs
l'ont perdu un petit peu la réplique de
Monsieur Lego de quoi parle-t-il de ces
14 études précisément le pont de
Tadoussac exactement
l'exemple était peut-être un peu niché
pour l'ensemble des spectateurs mais je
les ai sur le troisième lit c'est quand
même fascinant que ça occupe autant de
place sur un thème aussi important que
l'environnement
c'est un dossier que je pense qui
intéresse tout le monde quand même qui
est spectaculaire qui polarisant de
façon très très claire donc vous le
disiez tout à l'heure mais il y a
plusieurs enjeux qui sont liés à ça sauf
qu'on a pas beaucoup débattu de de de
réduction des gaz à effet de serre un
petit peu quand même mais peut-être pas
autant que qu'on aurait pu je souligne
une chose que que monsieur duem a dit
par rapport au troisième lien lorsqu'il
dit à Monsieur le goût votre projet en
2018 c'était un pont sur l'île d'Orléans
en vérité c'est pas ça c'était davantage
d'un tunnel et ensuite le pont de
l'autre côté de l'île d'Orléans
oui sans aucune raison d'ailleurs pour
décider que ça serait centre-ville à
centre-ville mais le projet de Monsieur
dum n'était pas le projet de Monsieur
Lego en 2018 est-ce que on est à jour le
d'élection est-ce que ce soir change
quelque chose pour quelqu'un pour être
les cinq chefs Sébastien je pense que
pour Dominique pour Dominique Anglade ça
lui permet de raffermir sa base
d'espérer sauver les meubles qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire sauver les mains passer
de 31 circonscriptions en 2018 à combien
en 2022
faudrait définir sauver les meubles mais
bon si elle reste opposition officielle
probablement qu'il aura sauvé les
meubles est-ce que ça lui garantit de
rester les chefs du parti libéral
peut-être pas mais ce soir elle devait
avoir une bonne performance elle a eu
une bonne performance c'est la propulse
potentielle du Premier ministre mais ça
lui permet au moins de sortir la tête
haute si on veut après des jours et des
jours on dit que ça roule carré où
pour rester à la taille du parti de
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais quand même je pense que et Madame
Anglade et Monsieur Saint-Pierre de La
Mondon peuvent espérer tirer un bénéfice
de ce débat parce que pour le PQ là a
gagné déjà il a gagné 4 points je pense
depuis une semaine aller en chercher
deux autres ou trois autres là c'est
toute la différence entre un deux trois
compter ou bien non 7 8 9 et ça c'est
très important pour le PQ pour Monsieur
saint-pierre-la-mondon alors ça ça peut
faire une différence madame anglais
j'ai peur que ça soit trop peu trop tard
dans son cas parce que son début de
campagne a été son début toute la
campagne a été tellement désastreuses je
pense c'est ce soir c'est le premier bon
coup ma foi qu'elle réalise depuis le
début de la campagne alors est-ce que
c'est pour réveiller est-ce que c'est
pour réveiller les libéraux
problèmes c'est le vote anglophone
et je sais pas quelle est la proportion
d'anglophone qui ont écouté le débat ce
soir mais je suis pas sûr non que ça va
l'aider les réveiller
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres extraits que
vous aimeriez entendre au fond qui
pourraient nous je sais pas c'est en
région on a trouvé peut-être que Valérie
veux intervenir sur ce qu'on vient de
dire je vous l'avais pas posé la
question à vous là peut-être effet
énergisant là effectivement du côté de
Madame Anglade et Paul Saint-Pierre
flamandon bon en tout cas peut-être une
fin de campagne plus agréable qu'elle ne
l'aurait été avant avant la performance
de ce soir pour
Eric jambes et je note on évoquait là
pour avoir le essentiellement comme
sujet il y a un certain plafonnement
peut-être puis même si ça a donné des
bons échanges on le vu sur la pandémie
on tente l'entrée qu'on reste un petit
peu dans les mêmes dans les mêmes os et
ce soir il loge clairement essayer de
sauver son siège je pense davantage aux
gens de Québec et c'est à eux qu'il a
parlé ce soir alors quelle suite
voyez-vous à cette campagne quelles sont
les stratégies qui vont se déployer pour
les uns pour les autres parce qu'il
reste du jour là ça va vite et
dis-moi où tu vas je te dirai ce que tu
essayes de faire c'est à dire que dans
les 7 derniers jours dans la dernière
semaine de la compagnie little là où les
caravanes des chèvres vont se rendre
c'est là où on veut dans certains cas
sauver les meubles dans d'autres cas
faire des des gains donc je sais pas
Dominique englade beaucoup à Montréal et
rids beaucoup à Québec
probablement François Lego va se
promener un peu partout le Parti
québécois va beaucoup être en guerre
dans le bassin Laurent Gaspesie donc
dans l'Est puis il me manque qu'avec
solidaire probablement Montréal
Sherbrooke c'est construction de
Saint-François donc ça va nous dire un
peu ce qu'ils essaient de faire selon
l'endroit où ils sont ok on me dit qu'on
est en régie qu'on a l'extrait de
Monsieur Nadaud Dubois on n'a pas
beaucoup entendu d'extraire monsieur
lequel extrait c'est sur la santé avec
Monsieur dum sur le privé socialiste
la présence du privé dans le système de
santé augmente d'année en année au
Québec une augmentation de 52% en 40
donc si le privé en santé ça marchait on
le saurait si le socialiste fonctionnait
en matière de santé monsieur Nadou
Dubois on le saurait ça fait 40 ans
qu'on a des ministres de la Santé qui se
promènent avec des structures qui
changent toutes les structures et
pourtant jamais on a eu des problèmes
jamais on a eu un système aussi
inefficace que celui qu'on a à l'heure
actuelle moi je pense monsieur Nadou
Dubois il faut emmener là on peut bien
jouer encore des structures une autre
fois ou deux autres fois mais la réalité
c'est que ça prend de la concurrence
alors Monsieur monsieur dum sur la
question de la santé c'était un peu plus
confus ce soir parce que le monsieur dum
la façon dont se présenter les choses ce
soir il dit pas tellement à autre chose
que François Legault il dit que vous
pouvez aller avec votre carte soleil
soit dans le privé soit dans le public
c'est pas ça la normalement qui nous dit
depuis le début c'est qu'il y aurait
deux systèmes parallèles qu'on
permettrait à des médecins de sortir
complètement c'est-à-dire de pratiquer
dans l'un ou dans l'autre mais ma
compréhension c'est quand il est dans le
privé dans cette on arrive avec la carte
de crédit et dans quand
même parce que vous payez votre
assurance tandis que là il essaye de
d'embrouiller les choses
remarquer lui il le dit la dernière fois
monsieur Legault vous proposiez ça quand
vous étiez à la CAQ dans l'opposition
d'essayer des projets privés privés et
monsieur Legault a renoncé à ça mais ce
que dans tête monsieur dum c'est
vraiment du privé
extraits intéressants parce que quand
même un choc des visions à travers ça
puis c'est vrai par contre que pour pour
ce qui est de la pédagogie autour de ces
quoi le privé de quel privé on parle
jusqu'où on est prêt à aller ça c'est
démonstration a pas été fait ce soir ni
dans le reste de médecins
il y a beaucoup d'infirmières des
agences privées etc écouter on va le
dernier tour parce qu'on était rendu à
vous Guillaume au Michel pour
à quoi s'attendre est-ce que c'est tout
le rappel des troupes en fait autant sur
les numéros chez les pékistes j'ai
l'impression puis peut-être que le débat
ce soir permettra où va redynamiser un
petit peu tout ça mais très certainement
et puis on l'entend notamment de la part
de Monsieur Saint-Pierre pour Mondon
mais c'est important d'aller chercher
cette base électorale qui existe encore
juste une note sur le PQ le PQ a fait
faire une actualisation des études des
finances d'un Québec souverain que
monsieur Legault avait fait il devait
les sortir pendant la campagne et
jusqu'à présent on l'a pas vu et mon
c'est qu'on a décidé de pas sortir ça
pour pas faire une distraction pour pas
que le débat sur la souveraineté part
sur la dette le déficit expériences il
faut payant
quelques secondes Valérie peut-être
monsieur Lebeau les déclarations on va
les surveiller jusqu'à maintenant des
controverses sont il les a amenés
lui-même mais alors d'abord bravo à
Patrice qui a amené ça de vraiment de
mettre bravo au chef qui ont bien
respecté les consignes qui nous ont
éclairés merci à vous à la maison
d'avoir suivi cet exercice très très
démocratique merci d'avoir suivi nos
analyses et bonne fin de campagne à vous
à la maison très bonne nuit bonne
réflexion aussi parce que quand même un
bon pourcentage d'un des si moi je donne
rendez-vous demain à 19h pour 24 heures
il est mordu aussi de parler
[Musique]